[Music]
two
one hello hello hello everybody happy
monday
we are here h3 tv
to entertain you
to
lay down my life for you
to sacrifice all i am and all i will
ever be
in the name of entertaining you my foot
soldiers whoo
i'm trying to match dan's energy today
baby's filling in for dan who's that
who's at the dentist he's still coming
right yeah he's coming yeah
yeah dan's at the dentist so
how's it feel they'd be to be in the hot
seat uh a little nerve-wracking but what
does he do there anyway like what do you
do um there's a few things actually
there's a lot of stuff going on handling
the calls discord
love boat
a lot of stuff
okay
excellent whoa
what he's hearing sound bite today's
episode is sponsored by curology
meundies
and hello fresh we love all of our
sponsors thank you
and if you guys want to call in
uh
the number is 808
hot meme you know the jail actually
don't have the call
program open which dan usually does but
oh i'll
so was that supposed to be you maybe um
thank you
yeah yeah you don't have to take the
blame for it if it's not your fault
you don't have to fall on your side i
honestly don't i honestly don't know
that's just we just we talked about it
right now the call-in thing i'll send
the link right here
yeah i mean it's a dan thing you don't
have to take you don't have to phone the
sword i don't expect that of you i'll
take the blame because i set up the
computer stuff today so that was michael
why didn't you do it today with the i'm
sorry i [ __ ] up it's okay it's okay
it's okay everyone i mean dan's not here
and uh things just fall at the wayside
um
man we have such a great episode we have
so much fun stuff to get to
it's a monday show that means we're
going for 10 hours we have just a
billion things to talk about
before we do
i want to plug one more time h3 shop the
[ __ ] ryan cavanaugh drop
oh my second monitor doesn't work either
my the show monitor doesn't work
it's gonna be a good day it's gonna be a
good day guys so wait it was working we
just had it yes so i can't drag anything
on for the can they see this ian
here no it's just an hdmi problem i'll
fix it right now
dan we need you where are you nothing
works i i can't but all these things i i
mean dan always fixes them but doesn't
usually do give me one sec
[Music]
you guys think about all this
[Music]
kind of need to have a
show monitor to do a show
it was working i mean how am i i can't
just i can't just ask them to imagine
what a video would look like
because without the monitor i can't show
them anything right that's how that
works
yeah
right he said correct
you know
[Music]
yeah why would i do that yeah because if
i for example if i don't have access to
the second monitor what happens ab
no show he said
uh ethan how was uh how was your
halloween buddy
halloween was fantastic actually it was
really fun
really nostalgic
nostalgic yeah because
i'll tell you why we went was theodore's
first time trick-or-treating you can
kill the music we'll just
okay we'll just actually talk about this
yeah we went to trick-or-treating with
theodore for the first time
and we went to a neighborhood in central
l.a my brother told me about i i wasn't
sure where to go i just wanted to go
when i was a kid i remember the streets
were packed halloween was like a massive
block party for everybody right
and i wanted to relive that magic for
theodore
and it was packed boy it was slammed
like in some cases shoulder to shoulder
uh it was fun it was great and theodore
was going crazy
at first he was very hesitant to go up
to the front door because i mean it is
inherently very weird right to just go
up to a neighbor's house and ask for
candy thank you av
you got the job
the monitor is back
but after like the second or third one
he's just he's running and he's going we
need more candy he's literally just
going
we need more candy
and he filled up he filled that bag up
and he had a lot of fun he didn't want
to go home so it was fun i i appreciated
being able to relive the magic
with my beautiful son
that's
instead of trick or treat i thought i
told him just to say fill that bag up
erin what what was his costume that he
dressed up here i have photos on
instagram which
i'll pull up yeah he had this amazing
cute little dinosaur costume and i
i don't know we lucked out with this one
i didn't see any other trick-or-treater
with this thing on
here's a video of it
and he would get super excited and start
running and you can see his tail wagging
so awesome
[Music]
here he goes
that's so awesome
yeah he was having so much fun it was so
cool
i was very grateful to all the
inhabitants of the uh
of the neighborhood
yeah cute looks like a great time yeah
it was beautiful it really was
yeah he filled this whole bag up man he
was so stoked
uh on the other end nobody came to my
neighborhood i put out a bass here let's
see if my stories are still up
i put up a whole
like crazy ass
oh by the way i'll tell you what i'm
scrolling through
yeah so i was on the front page of joe
rogan which i appreciated big dubs there
big dubs for big nips these were the
dogs this was what this is what you
would be greeted with if you were a
trick-or-treater well i'm used to not
getting the potential anymore
so here's the spread we're gonna do a
before and after so
this is before
we got all the treats we got
all the treats all the treasures okay
i'll check
okay
and then after you're gonna be wondering
what's going on here cake pops
ghosty cake pop pumpkin cookies
chocolate chip cookies rice krispie
treats zombie cookies it's all happening
and something tells me
it'll all come out here
uh exactly the same
five hours later
untouched all right you guys tell me is
anything missing
no maybe one rice crispy i don't know no
i don't know
this morning there was stuff gone though
i wonder if like delivery people have
been snagging treats which i'm totally
fine with
i'm happy about that you know you had
the ultimate spread man [ __ ] yeah you
know i mean i wanted to be but well
nobody got it
whatever
not surprised our neighborhood's not
very inviting
uh anyway h3 how was your guys halloween
it was cool me and uh lena went to the
halloween horror nights at universal
surprisingly really good um was it
actually like scary or just fun yes sort
of because the audio is so good inside
the haunted houses it's so loud that
like it's unavoidable that you have some
jump scares oh man yeah
wait how does it work they set up
haunted mansions that you walk through
yeah they sent up and they use some of
the uh sound stages so it's pretty cool
they're really big and they're legit
yeah
oh i should have known they were doing
that yeah dan said it was good so if dan
likes it then
i shouldn't have second guess dan the
hater yeah endorses something you better
listen right
definitely not anyone else have a good
halloween
i uh i went to a party with my
girlfriend uh saturday night um
and then last night i spent it with the
folks
so it was uh it was pretty fun
nice yeah
uh sam and i uh it's actually our
anniversary today uh two years no way
two years at the university you guys are
welcome all i accept thank yous every
year for uh putting you guys together
thank you
uh but we went to uh i'll be your best
man right if that happens we'll we'll
we'll talk about it i'll have to look at
the guest list
[Laughter]
oh we went to like a couple's massage
i've never done that before oh fun
and the guy he just he was going he was
going up the leg very high he got up in
that grendel area you're not telling me
about it in the right did it move
no it was
it was staying solid but you know well
not solid it was actually not solid not
solid well you said you got a tingle
right i did not say that
zach was very inquisitive about the
tingle but uh so it didn't move you're
here saying today you're pledging on
them
no moving no movement
but uh he was flicking he just kept
accidentally touching the
sack a little bit
[Laughter]
i don't think they're supposed to touch
your stack dude
i don't know if that was part of it or
not but he gave you a sack massage
just a little bit so so let me ask you
this he went high up the thigh nicked
the sack like a like a
unintentional sack naked he was going
like up the thighs like this
and then the thumbs here
were kind of like
i was like
i i appreciate that he's up getting in
that area being thorough but
yeah and you were wearing underwear
right you you were you were just wearing
underwear yes so did his thumbs touch
your sack skin was it no he didn't go
under okay it was just a little wait you
weren't nude no i don't care massages
hell no you get naked we put the towel
over you yeah [ __ ] no i leave my
underwear on
okay
zach you are the type of guy yeah he's
gonna say that and they're like they're
like excuse me sir we don't do that
around here
well what's wrong you got a towel
covering over you it's not like anything
provocative no i think it's fine to get
nude but i just don't want to i don't
want to make that presumption i don't
want you know what i mean yeah let's
watch too many the under movies too many
uh
nc 17 movies yeah yeah sure let's go
let's go
you ever yours ever moved during a
massage zach
no
i can't say it i have a bad
well okay how was yours sam did any i
mean did
oh right
was she violated in any way or was she
okay no i think she you know
had a good time but okay we both
experienced this
we don't know who's gonna come walk in
and do the massage and there's these two
big dudes came in and
they had on like thin pants
oh my god and every time he would walk
behind i'm flat on my stomach with my
feet back he would walk behind me
and the room was tiny
and i would
i would feel his like dick on my foot no
[ __ ] way
not a lot just like a little like oh
that's what that is
huh by the way usually when i do a
couple of massages they they ask if i
have a gender preference
i don't know sam uh i don't you guys
find these guys on craigslist or what no
they
we didn't get the option we have an
update from sam she messaged the man's
ball grazed my heel
a single ball interesting one single
ball bob ballior
lots of balls grazing during the session
it's an interesting time
sam i'm going to come sam said they
didn't ask about that
[Music]
that's very interesting was it where did
you get it down was it a spa or what
i mean you don't name this the location
i'm just curious
yeah it was um
just a primary like massage place um
had good reviews sam said it was a
groupon that explains it oh
okay when you when you when you do a
groupon massage expect some balls to you
guys here two balls for the price of one
yeah at the groupon college honks to
move your junk dude that's funny
sorry ian she's apologizing for outing
you for the groupon experience that's
okay it was otherwise good couple
experience that's besides the balls and
the dick on the foot
chet is calling the guy the unibalmer
the una bomber the uniballer yes it's
awesome
thanks for sharing it's nice to hear
from you
that's a fantastic uh
spit up my green drink there when i
heard about the am touching your balls
man there's sometimes though i've had
massages where they get like they push
it too far
they go deep
i had a massage when me and either were
in mexico i think or maybe it was
thailand i don't remember i was on my
back and it was a girl
not and like it was an old lady it
wasn't like a sexual fantasy i just want
to make that clear
and she was riding right up like on my
upper thighs right into my crotch and it
was
she didn't like touch anything but i was
like dude i don't know it was very close
to everything happening
it's the massage is an interesting
experience
it is it's weird it's like you would
never let anyone touch you in such an
intimate way right but also when you go
to the massage and people got their
hands all over your on your weirdest
parts of your body that's right i also
just remembered that
they had like the nice spa music like
the birds and the sounds or whatever
halfway through the music just died
it's so
it was just the noise of skin and
and that and the guy he was like a
bigger guy and he was going like
he's breathing so heavy
takes his job seriously yeah
it didn't sound like that
the tight white
fabric does seem like something out of a
film
of adult orientation
you know
was he torqued or no
yeah
not that i noticed right okay i wasn't
looking
they didn't want to know
wait talked in the sense that he'd get
wood yes okay chubbed up just clarifying
anyway
h3 shop [ __ ] ryan cavanaugh dropped
you guys still have until
uh
november 24th
to get yours to say [ __ ] you ryan
kavanagh you [ __ ]
this is the certified lover boy the the
preview is gone again
why they keep doing that
they don't show the back on the website
but here it is do you get do you have
your passport did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back to rob
with america
this is some beautiful fan art and then
finally
a courtroom reenactment of uh judge
klein sentencing
frank kavanagh
for his crimes against humanity oh maybe
that's why it scrolls to the right
uh govern yourself accordingly i tell
him which is what he deemed me
when he damned me all belligerent
uh so there you have it h3h3shop.com
thank you thank you
thank you thank you mistress
yeah i was on the top of the joe rogan i
showed that already but w is all around
folks you think joe's going to see this
is there a chance
probably i think jamie's on there a lot
so he'll probably send his way something
different about joe i was reading i
don't know sometimes i get on the
subreddit i don't know if it's real or
not but people joe rogan fans were mad
about this
that can't be can it
i don't know
they might be protective of his nips so
dude this is an awesome costume come on
you you guys are here let me okay
joe's nipples are bigger yeah okay sorry
that was the top comment
sorry i uh
i wasn't dedicated enough they won the
nobel prize and giant nips
oh one other thing this thursday i know
people look forward to this sale every
year
we haven't announced it on social media
but this thursday at 10 am pst we are
doing teddy fresh huge black friday sale
we're doing it early and running it
through the whole month of november i
suspect a lot of shit's going to sell
out immediately though
so this thursday set your alarms if
you're interested 30 to 50 off almost
every item
um
that's it set your alarms folks we're
going to post about it though soon
tomorrow
also halloween our little halloween wrap
up
zach got a shout out this is pretty epic
dude
from sharon osborne yeah that was really
cool this is pretty [ __ ] cool she
said
no no no
i just i'd like screenshot it and
reposted it oh she just she just
re-posted yeah yeah yeah
how about that huh yeah it was it was
pretty cool um
as you saw that means probably i hope
yeah i really hope
yeah that was can he register anything
he sees these days or he can't even
speak the poor man
oh congrats on that thank you pretty
awesome thank you
um
this is such a weird video
i i guess this is top of the show
material it's just so weird kevin
specifically from the office has been
getting into all kinds of weird
shenanigans this is an ad that just
showed up on my tick tock page
so this is an ad just just uh bear that
in mind as you watch it
this seems like a cameo gone wrong or
something
listen if you served in the military
between 2003 and 2015
and you've developed any sort of hearing
loss time is running out
uh to claim your cash settlement now
this is i guess you're entitled this is
like uh reverse mortgage vibes but way
way way worse
just alone it's just a loan
to a cash settlement if you've developed
some hearing loss uh due to some
defective combat earplugs
that that were issued to you i am so
sorry click
uh on the link to join over 200 000
veterans just like you demanding justice
i'm not sure why they thought i was a
good target for this
i don't think
the chances of based on my social media
presence of me being an ex-veteran is
probably zero
so
for for this defective equipment uh most
of you
you have no idea how much you can even
qualify for so get the compensation you
you deserve uh click on the link and uh
my best to each
and every one of you brought to you by
sal goodman
uh
do you think this is a cameo gone wrong
or he's because i mean there's no way
that he doesn't know this is for
commercial use that's for sure yeah he
was the biggest earner in 2020 on cameo
no wonder he didn't say no to [ __ ]
he made over 1 million damn it tick tock
what the [ __ ] i'm just trying to wat
just need y'all to come
come here baby girl
come here baby girl
[Laughter]
dude these cowboy thirst straps are
still coming in hot
just to remind you i am the victor of
the weird tick tock uh home
so shout out kevin from the office
his new gig is uh
just as fulfilling
let's help those veterans out shall we
so you can retire better
what the [ __ ] is that
tom selleck but what was the so you can
that was a name it was from the ad
bless you bless you
excuse me
that was from the bad yeah it was from
that
phase blanks
um we've clearly been getting to phase
blanks because
this dude this [ __ ] guy posted an iq
test to his instagram stories today
which is pretty embarrassing
i mean that's like 13 year old [ __ ]
right there
um dude
scott lee we've really hit struck a
nerve in him the phase blanks
he's who does that i mean how old is he
ab
i believe he is 30 let me double check
though you don't sorry dude but you
can't be posting iq test results at 30.
it's just yes he's 30. it's cringe bro
you posted cringe i'm infinitely smart
and let me also just stay for the record
more successful there's zero [ __ ]
percent chance you have a 138 iq i'm
sorry but
no
[ __ ] fraudulent you literally don't
you probably have a
38 iq
no he's not he's not like
diminished but i mean 138
i mean that's probably like a facebook
quiz
for sure yeah yeah definitely
blanks the whole iq testing
is such a poor way of measuring
intelligence i think it's like i don't
know why we as a society have bought
into this notion that like
the iq test is this ultimate test of
intelligence i mean all the iq tests
does is test
like memory
pattern recognition stuff like that
which is certainly a
dimension of intelligence but there's so
many other dimensions of intelligence
that couldn't possibly be measured on
this test with like creativity
you know
humor
uh artistry
interpersonal skills these are all
uh some like intelligent aspects that
people
develop and yet uh
what the [ __ ] are you saying i mean this
is the guy right sorry from maybe i'm
speaking to uh
but this is the guy that was shilling a
milf coin okay
138
sorry yeah
yeah
my voice correct god damn it
but yeah
100 is the average score
for the iq test
have you ever taken an iq test ethan no
i don't want to know
it'd be low
i've never taken one either but the
thing is you can't take like an iq test
is administered by a professional you
know psychologist under a strict uh like
to do it properly but again it's just a
really bad way to judge someone's
intelligence
yeah yeah i agree it's like
majority retention
i believe
has anyone taken an iq test oh yeah i
took one on facebook actually yesterday
it said i was 160. holy [ __ ] so actually
still infinitely smarter than phase
blanks 140 is high iq 160 is just 160 is
off the charts i'm the smartest man that
ever lived well according to phase
blanks he is not
your iq was measured uh higher than 99.5
percent of the people in the whole
planet so are you smart enough to for
menza let's go wait wait is he smart
enough for menza norway
interesting uh nate she's going for
there
i think he's [ __ ] stupid
you know what mensa iq challenge let's
let's pop this open let's see what this
[ __ ] idiot actually took
let's see
mensa iq challenge
yeah
oh my god this is it you guys
we found that
we've a mensa iq norway okay i am uh 18
to 50.
oh [ __ ]
am i really going to do this how long is
this sick
this is going to be boring
try a couple
uh well i gotta like here i gotta read
all this and see i i i don't know i'm
just gonna
okay look exercise one the answer is
clearly
b
okay b b b
b test section takes approximately two
hours
well let's just see how much he did you
[ __ ] spent your whole day doing this
banks you freak dude you're so insecure
look how much he did he did all this
yeah but look it's like oh oh
b doesn't work okay ethan
i'm already fail i can't oh finish we're
finished all right i did b on all
let's see how smart i am
b on all
with time remaining
legend iq
your iq lies outside the area that the
test is available to measure damn
i'm [ __ ] off the charts i'm up to
charge people
it can't be measured
it simply cannot be measured
it's awesome off the charts but always
wait what olivia said
yeah i mean sam we're talking about on
the side she's just uh having some
problems with the call-in okay but the
the audience can hear yeah the audience
is fine okay good
i'm sorry banks i think you're smart
don't don't worry you're a smart guy
and you're infinitely you're infinitely
smart and infinitely successful
okay wait let's try this again i
actually want to get a score and see
how it compares to the blank let's do a
hey d it dude i can't believe he did all
these what the hell bro you you're like
you're apparently this
he's infinitely smart he's so busy and
he's time for all this [ __ ]
weightlessness
oh lord
damn i'm too dumb
too or too smart
all right enough of that
thank you
so shout out to banks he's a genius
another one at the top of the show which
i think is [ __ ] awesome logan paul
who recently
got basically trashed and attacked
somebody has come out with this
statement
that he's going to be president
president of the united states one day
yeah i really think so i think uh the
united states need to
unite
yo that's such a good insight
[Laughter]
he's right we need to unite
the united states he's the great uniter
[Applause]
damn
i think i can actually do it bro i'm
[ __ ]
up like
trust me you're gonna want the dude who
made the mistakes
who made the mistakes
rather than the dude who's making them
now you know what i'm saying and and i'm
26
me at 35. yeah at you and 35 you'll be
in rehab bro not the [ __ ] not running
for office sorry to tell you based on
the videos i've seen it could be pretty
interesting to see gp run around those
white houses gp for vp gp for vp
father sun duo that's a great position
to pick up some young some young tale
too for gp oh yeah power cop and uh
in the uh royal the royal the
presidential guardian in his van
the white house will be a clout house
for sure it would yeah
you got mike who's like the treasurer or
some [ __ ]
what does that look like mike would be
the uh
secretary of state
yeah gp could be the uh
the press secretary that would be good
yeah
that'd be awesome and then um
jake would be the you know
secretary of uh defense defense for sure
of course who better than him
it's a boxing war he's good at wars for
no reason yeah
uh lena rhodes or sorry what's her name
lana
lana rhodes would be the um
well she she would actually be a great
press secretary yeah
yeah
she's used to being on camera so
fantastic i love this cabinet
what a duck what a freak to actually i
mean this guy is actually psychotic he's
coming out here and saying i'm going to
be president i'm going to be president
of the united states i'm going to i mean
it's not like cute or ambitious it's
just weird bro
i think uh the united states need to
unite
and uh
you guys try not to laugh at him bro
i've
yeah i mean you like literally removed
ads off youtube for like everybody for a
whole year and so
let's let's focus on maybe i don't
really give a [ __ ] but thanks for
letting me know
right
yeah you also have to be willing to
sacrifice some little bit of your
liberty
or not liberty but make small sacrifices
right for the country for example like
wearing a mask
logan paul what do you think about
wearing a mask during the heidelkov i
don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks for
letting me know
right
okay
that'll play well during the campaign
i'm sure all the other countries in the
world would be happy to see logan paul
as our president you know he's always
represented us well
everywhere he goes well you know all
these p all these goons see trump and
then they say because trump was trump
was a guy that nobody ever thought would
be president or should be president
right
and um
so you know they see trump and they go i
can do this [ __ ] and you know actually
they're [ __ ] right i'll tell you one
thing though japan would immediately
seize all trade and friendly
communications japan is out
trump told the nelson boys one of them
could be president one day so you never
know dude that's that's the thing about
trump he's kind of right yeah
i mean trump has like 50 allegations
against him he has bankrupted every
business endeavor he's been involved in
and the people love him
he lost the election and he says he's
still the president lost by seven
million votes man
nationally
i am god bless
what is this i like it but i don't know
what it is cam
uh this is you selecting b on every
option
yeah they can't gauge my intelligence
250 billion iq
i'm dr manhattan
thank you again that's good
love that
okay so let's get to some maine
some main pieces here
trailers trailers on my nuts
brian cavanaugh's [ __ ] with me like
there's no question about it right for
sure
i like that though he's petty enough to
try to beef with me he thinks he's such
a big shot but like are you really
if you're getting if you're tumbling
around with me are you a big shot no
by the way if you guys want to go to um
if we might have some new content if you
type ryan
or does ryan cavanaugh
look like harvey weinstein you know
what's funny
oh there's actually a couple articles
about it now it's awesome yeah these
guys the focus wrote an article shout
out
this is a really hard hitting article by
the focus
yasmine
long sorry if i said that wrong i'm sure
i did
does ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein h3 website debunks it thank
you that's what we're here to debunk
that uh amazing
yeah so so she wrote a whole article
about it and she goes look um they
you know they went through all this
effort to debunk this
this rumor if anything ryan should be
thanking me so people know that they're
different people
yeah so they announced after dark
in the same font
trailers concert is not only
suspiciously titled after dark but the
artwork has many similarities
including the brick wall and neon font
oh yeah and then we started [ __ ] with
them in the
uh twitter thread and then he they
started
hiding all the comments
your [ __ ] is flipped i mean that's
proven probably true
see here look it's all flipped
right
and then he started hiding all of our uh
a b posted his flips
costume
you fell off plus ratio plus bankruptcy
got hidden
ratio you fell off bankruptcy plus swali
will never get paid google ryan kavanagh
controversy
sway lee sorry thank you
oh so awkward did yours get hidden oh
you just did too
okay
did anyone watch that how was that
i didn't watch it i don't know if anyone
else did
no no one else watching i don't think
anyone watched everywhere anywhere i saw
some photos it looked like there's like
two or three people there
yeah i mean what the [ __ ] is that what
is he's just like in the business of
wasting money
how anyone invests in that man is is
truly baffling
here's the tweet there's some good stuff
here
good feedback
uh joint trailer after dark for an
exclusive halloween celebration in the
heart of new orleans
with swaley trailer after dark dot com
uh by the way it had like 20 likes
before we started uh getting in on
direction now it's up to 90. so you know
trill is really popping off
i seen someone say that every cast
member got more likes than the original
post yeah ratio it's so hard bro
actually the best part about this is if
you go how do i look at the hidden
replies because that is obviously
the best part to the right below the
picture
i
right here
yeah okay so wait it's so dark on my
yeah so here's all the good stuff you
fell off ratio bankruptcy your trailer
[ __ ] has flipped they hit all these
man this makes me want to falsify me too
information
ugh it's so awkward only 50 likes no
one's watching this [ __ ]
uh ratio you fell off bankruptcy
looks like somebody's been watching a
little too much h3 they're trying to
censor you bro that one got hidden
look at all these that they hid
look at this
somebody's working over you think ryan
himself is just hiding replies
look at all these replies it's like what
the [ __ ] who's doing all this
you should be thankful you're even
getting interaction on twitter at all i
mean [ __ ]
let's look at the recent post two hours
ago three likes
three likes
this is trailer people the the supposed
biggest social media network
three [ __ ] likes
come on now
two hours
my mom my mom crushes you on social bro
my mom
must have a market share of a billion
dollars compared to
this one from three years ago has one
like so
and shout out to the social media team
whatever the [ __ ] this is look at this
what is this what am i this is the worst
social post ever and this is a social
media platform
today on trailer look at this what is
this supposed to mean
what is this
one like
one like frank kavanagh what the [ __ ] is
this
and they're all and all the comments are
about uh bit being flipped which is uh
they admit in their recent filing so not
flipped said it's inverted is how they
phrased it yeah yeah inverted but i
can't help but notice always the
difference the discrepancy between how
many followers and how many likes ron
cavanaugh's accounts and the trailer
accounts well fifty thousand
rank governor has like millions we call
them buying followers by 50 yeah
allegedly but
well well
no
okay allegedly but here i'll let you
decide we found uh a company
whatever you guys saw it i don't explain
the [ __ ] buys views
oh yeah 50 000 followers allegedly and
one like everybody got you though you
know that's
pretty bad yeah it's almost like nobody
cares
it's almost like
yeah so and then that wasn't the only
slight we
also what bro what the [ __ ]
kanye west now is doing sunday services
um
ian pick your side is the title of this
ian what'd you think
didn't didn't watch you're lying
i didn't watch i can confirm that we
asked him before the show and he said he
didn't watch okay did anyone watch thank
you ian
i was
you know
getting some guy massaging my thigh and
getting those nuts flicked but yeah
i'm so sorry to interrupt
we got to do an ad break
all right thank you baby
[Music]
cam said he skimmed it you want to talk
about it cam or it's just like a bunch
of religious stuff
cam said they have a tweet about kanye
and all has 13 likes
it was just kanye west and marilyn
manson which is such a weird mix i can't
get over that
why how are they even getting the word
out about anything it's like okay oh
yeah kanye tweeted it kanye posted it
kali how much does it cost to get kanye
to do that it's gotta cost
millions i mean he won't get out of bed
for less than that
i would think so yeah at least i mean
he's worth a billion dollars so
i don't think a hundred thousand dollars
something like that would cut it
also considering literally nobody will
watch it right
that's a big factor as well
yeah so
anyway actually you know i do have
exciting news and we'll do the ads after
this hey b thank you for reminding me
ryan cavan if you google ryan cavanaugh
okay
let's just see
some kind of interesting results here if
you go to images
here here he is with
harvey weinstein that's interesting
but if you go back
and just go down
this is what i
i wanted to show you guys and possibly
even for you to do it yourself to see
that i'm not lying right love
yeah it's further down on pc about the
mobile it's on the first page
oh it is
it should be right there so here it is
so if you type ryan kavanaugh's name
you'll find that our website is
is uh
coming closer to the top
does which means google thinks it's
relevant for his name which you know it
is yeah it's the most relevant very
relevant so love what should people do
to kind of just
to prove them that this is actually
this is a real i want to show people
that this is real what you want to do
it's very important that you yeah yeah
yeah so google ryan kavanagh you know it
might take take a couple pages to find
it but once you find it press it stay on
the page for at least two minutes that
that's very important that you take the
time to read everything read the content
and refresh it a couple times examine
yeah
notice the deadness in both their eyes
do you see it that
that could be what's the confusing
factor there
you know go down we're constantly adding
content too
so don't be afraid to visit it every day
anything else you want to add multiple
times per day
anything you know there there's another
thing i was thinking about if you happen
to have a vlog like an actual blog or a
website feel free to
make
or send us some links send your traffic
to us because that that's just great
honestly it's gonna send so much traffic
so
gets out there you know yeah and well we
can review it on the website on our
podcast too because
i just think this is so important that
the public understand like
i don't think it's fair to ryan
that people confuse him with harvey
weinstein such a terrible guy
like like ryan
kavanaugh should be able to stand on his
own two feet as a man an individual and
say i am ryan cavanaugh not harvey
weinstein don't don't put me and him
together in the same words even
here's what
don't even put us together in the same
sentence god forbid
anyway here's photos of them together
side by side oh yeah oh the yep
right and this is you know this is your
time if you have a website this is your
time to do something good for the world
uh to you know share something good
share the word you know it's just just a
good thing to do for everyone in the
world it's [ __ ] beautiful
i like this website i think it's a vital
public service ryan cavanaugh a public
figure harvey weinstein a public figure
um
you know
nothing wrong about that
yeah and then we're gonna add some new
content here too right love
oh yeah quizzes uh all that stuff it's
gonna be really fun so make sure to go
go in and check every day
baby are you okay man
what you can
are you laughing i i don't know it just
[ __ ] hit me just how far this is
going it's [ __ ] hilarious
i don't know what you're talking about
how that the soundbite got me the
kenneth copeland
how far is going with kenneth copeland
yeah yeah
yeah we might want to do
yeah it's exciting i'm really excited
about that i mean it's already gotten so
much traction like it's on the first and
second page that's phenomenal for his
first name
i mean with any
with any you know luck we might even be
ranking first that would be the dream
right love
absolutely and it will happen
i've been uh i've been using all dancers
to link oh thank you oh my goodness
thank you guys
thanks for having me it's been a little
train wreck without av i mean what they
be the show was you were watching oh
well in my car the [ __ ] tv didn't
work
i wasn't logged in to call studios oh
god oddly enough all the stuff you
prepped me for worked fine
for some reason this stuff zac usually
takes care of it it was working fine
went to [ __ ]
so anyway yeah
but man i'm happy to see you
maybe we could even make a game i wonder
if we can make oh well maybe that's a
problem we're not maybe it's a free game
we can't like the problem is you can't
uh
monetize his name but you can
yeah maybe not a game if it's a free
game
there's got to be more we can do on that
website just to make it a fun fulfilling
experience
absolutely
okay well anyway um good job everybody
on that front love to see that progress
there
um
let's do a let's check the calls let's
see if oh i got to do ads all right
let's take our ads real fast then we'll
do into a couple of collins
what do you got drug painkillers
wait wait wait what um what what did you
get done
uh
the first stage of getting an implant so
like they drilled a [ __ ]
little your mic's needed
oh jesus oh god start over oh god i got
the first stage of getting an implant so
they put the like the little base screw
thing into my you're getting
removed completely or it's already gone
that tooth is gone and it's getting
replaced with an implant you're getting
a molar a new tooth new tooth baby new
tooth new man so did you get messed up
today
uh i'm in a decent amount of pain right
now
they give you vicodin what kind yeah
what kind of drugs you get oh nothing
that anything logan paul would like
norco this is way too yeah this is just
ibuprofen so this is i hate when doctors
do that it's like yeah thanks i can buy
ibuprofen from the groceries yeah but
this is like okay it's 600 milligrams
did you say ivermectrin or ibuprofen
oh i already have my script forever and
i've been taking that for a while now i
don't know why doctors give prescription
for ibuprofen i just find it insulting
yeah it's like they're like it's 600
yeah you mean two
right
he screwed you down
you deserve better
anyway curology
thank you thank you with peace and love
we love curology
um skin care is so important it really
is
and i've been out of the game for a long
time just because i couldn't
i couldn't get into it i didn't know
what to buy
i didn't know what to use and the great
thing about curology is they make it
easy
you work with licensed dermatology
providers
to get you a perfect formulation of what
you need
you send in photos of your skin you take
a quiz
and they send you a perfect formulation
uh to help you tackle
uh
basically anything acne
fine lines dark spots occasional
breakouts clogged pores
start by answering questions online
about your skin if it's a good fit
curology we'll match you with a licensed
dermatology provider and you'll get to
know your skin
subject to consultation you'll get a
customized prescription cream to be
stripped
shipped straight to your door how this
is how it worked for me i got the
the formula
cream
a face wash which is super gentle gentle
cleanser
and a moisturizer it's a three-step
process and that's it they send you the
perfect products exactly for you
and i'm doing this routine now for a
while and it honestly feels great it's
so nice too
to do it this way because i don't want
to go to a dermatologist get invested in
all this [ __ ] you know it's like such a
time sink and it's confusing bro i went
to a dermatology recently and they they
literally try to upsell you [ __ ] while
you're in the office like these guys are
straight schemers
dude was like yo you need this
particular anti-aging cream with his
name on it interesting that was like a
hundred bucks i was like get the [ __ ]
out of here
cure algie's where it's at
it's the real deal
so guys um you can start your curology
journey just like i did with a free
30-day trial at curology.com h3 and if
prescribed
just pay five dollars for shipping and
handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash h3 to
unlock your free 30-day trial thank you
thank you peace and love
me undies let's go
thank you me undies
oh it's thanksgiving time over meundie's
world are you ready for mashed potato
seasons aka turkey with gravy and
cranberry sauce season aka every kind of
pie and more season yes
well
if you're gonna eat turkey you better
also have turkeys on your underwear yeah
turkey
but it's not just about turkeys let's be
real meundies makes the most comfortable
breathable next level underwear to up
your game because we're not babies
anymore we buy our own underwear
it's time to get rid of those underwear
that's disintegrating
and step it up to big boy underwear
that's super comfortable
and when you drop trout let me tell you
you're gonna impress
you are you're like damn this guy's
interesting or girl
with adventurous prints to choose from
and plenty of ways to match everyone in
the family
give your gratitude give your gratitude
some attitude this thanksgiving
with me undies they have und undies and
loungewear made out of soft breathable
stretchy fabric that are perfect for
everything from pre-dinner activities to
post dinner naps seriously you won't
even care if the turkey's a little dry
with undies this comfortable
right
that's interesting
available in sizes through xs through
4xl and tons of styles prints and
fabrics communities has a little of
something for everyone at the table and
for our listeners mandy's has a great
offer for you
for any first time purchaser you get 15
off and free shipping me undies also has
a promise if you're not 100 satisfied
with any product for any reason you can
return your order for a full refund
within 45 days so to get your 50 off
your first order free shipping 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
myannies.com h3tv that's meundies.com
h3tv thank you
and finally
hello fresh
coming at you
with those spicy hot fresh affordable
fun easy cook at home recipes
it's why it's america's number one meal
kit folks
the holidays can be hectic but
hellofresh keeps things simple with
recipes and ingredients that cut out
grocery shopping and limit meal prep
time so you can spend more time
with the family
and you're going to be eating more
delicious food let's be honest
this food slaps hard do we have any new
recipes to show
we do we do actually
courtesy of a fupa trooper i want to see
a b cook again after that
i do want to see i want to give you a
chance to redeem yourself i've been
using hellofresh i'll i'll get some
pictures
wait oh so this is coming from super
troopers from discord yes indeed oh
that's awesome pub style shepherd's pie
with white cheddar and thyme mashed
potatoes dude that looks so good
and a honey miso sweet potato and shroom
jumble
it's a jumble
that's awesome yeah i mean everybody who
gets hello fresh i feel like it's like
universal satisfaction
it's fun
if you're not great at cooking it's a
way to kind of learn a lot of the basic
stuff as they tell you what to do you
don't have to measure ingredients
it's a great experience it really is
and also they have
uh 50 menu and market items to choose
from every week including vegetarian
calorie smart gourmet options
they got plenty of variety to choose
from so go to hellofresh.com
h3tv14 and use code h3 tv 14 for
up to 14 free meals what the freak
and three free gifts
once again
hellofresh.com
h3tv14 and use code h34 h3 tv 14 for 14
free meals let's go
and guys this is america's number one
meal kid for a reason so we thank you we
love you
all
right my calling studio is
it booted everybody off i actually just
reconnected it so if you just pop on
there um they're just
now uh
getting the screening happening should
we just bail on it they had everything
up there no
well they like what they gotta restart
from scratch i'd rather get olivia down
here
well they're already okay i see them
loadings just give it a few minutes
let's do uh let's do another story and
then we'll uh we'll take a call how do i
do it my shows
yeah
okay i don't see anything on it
you want me to hack your mainframe and
set it up for you
um
let me hack your mainframe okay let me
get up in there okay dan is a great guy
let me get up in your main frame my dog
okay all right maybe
okay
don't worry don't worry
i got you
show host he's clicking here let's put
this on screen or maybe we shouldn't it
shows people's names yeah that's just
people's numbers okay that was that was
really easy
um it's all right i'm here everything's
gonna be okay
everything's gonna be great
we're having a good show
okay moving on thank you peace and love
how's your halloween
thank you the audience has already heard
this conversation
it was good
yeah it was good [ __ ] how was yours
that's a new conversation for everyone
it was good
yeah uh yeah i went to a halloween party
why do you say it like that just because
i don't know i haven't been to a party
in a year and a half yeah i think it's
the pandemic
uh so that was cool
saw a bunch of old friends i haven't
seen a long time
you get trashed
not trashed i'm too old for that [ __ ]
now yeah me too yeah i swear if i if i
drink too much i i'm like my whole week
is done yeah
literally
i had like maybe three drinks over the
course of five or six hours so dude
people who are alcoholics must be
feeling real bad because that's just got
to be like hangover after hangover after
hangover that's got to be so bad
yeah you know alcohol is actually i saw
this
harm of drugs maybe you could find it
maybe
it was basically rated each drug um
based on its harm to society
and to the individual and everything all
factored together it's got to be up
there with like meth and heroin right
alcohol was number one by far by far
yeah by far that doesn't surprise me at
all yeah
uh meth and heroin were
were not
maybe in the top 10 but surprisingly low
sure
it's really interesting actually if you
can find it
maybe marijuana was actually pretty high
up on the list as well
oh then that study's bogus yeah exactly
marijuana doesn't cause cancer
discounting the entire thing based off
of that piece of information that i
don't like
new uh oh there's some new quartering
cringe this is so good you guys oh my
god
the quartering cringe this sent me an
orb it's such a freak show
there's [ __ ] all over the floor
how do i even set this up um
the quartering has been talking to this
girl
he had her on his show right gina
carrano carano yes the woman from the
mandalorian who got fired for like was
it like q and on conspiracy stuff she's
not anti-backs i think it was everything
i mean i think she's everything yeah
here i'll show you a picture of her to
set it up
i mean she was on his shows i mean which
is kind of weird for her like damn
that's rock bottom i think for an
actor
yeah this is her from a starring role on
a star wars uh property too yeah so you
guys are with the quartering if you
watch the mandalorian you definitely
remember her
and she was posting cringe so she got
canned
um let's see let's see her collab with
the quartering was she for sure on his
show like
i have nearly 50 videos on the woman
five hours
what the [ __ ] is this
wait this [ __ ]
has a five-hour video
about gina carano
what is this
okay i need to take this all in here
let's explore a little bit okay wait
kids in the cages
okay is is she here
gina carl fights back mega
stream with huge guests
they did a whole mega stream to defend
her when she was canceled i see i see
all the usual uh suspects who we got
here
you recognize any of these other
jokers uh not really actually
why do they all have
toys mario out of it blue led lighting
they all look like they're in their
thing quartering's basement
mario totally would have been a january
uh
sixth
or fifth six
he totally would have a january six uh
protester writer
he's so cool
yeah he actually has more videos about
her than brie larson
wait did he do an interview with her
like where the [ __ ] is this well he just
recorded it i i don't know
because he was just tweeting about it
all excited okay
so he did it he did an interview with
her
which means that they were in proximity
they were talking which makes all that
happen afterwards even creepier yeah you
would think you would have some
semblance of respect
for this girl uh pre a professionality
and as you see he's already made 20
videos about her
so
get ready i am of course
a white supremacist
i don't know if we've moved on but
here's that chart oh yeah this is
actually we can do this so you have harm
to user harm to others go up to the top
and read that ranked by drug experts on
damage to users impact on crime and
socioeconomic effects
so i'm assuming harm to others is like
socioeconomic effects impact on crime
well and i mean with alcohol you could
probably lump in you know drunk driving
accidents uh domestic abuse
like all all of the baggage that comes
along with alcoholism yeah so when all
factors are
accumulated alcohol
crushes heroin which is a number two
marijuana isn't i mean i guess it's sort
of high but it i mean it's up i mean
you'd be surprised because people people
like to pretend like marijuana is a
completely [ __ ] harmless drug yo
that's what i'm talking about mushrooms
numbers are at the end
zero yeah that's interesting it has zero
negative effects on society apparently
i don't know how can they say that zero
i mean this is one study it's from 2010
and it's in the uk um so this is not
dude
universal mushrooms never hurt nobody
dude
that's what i'm saying dude i'm seeing
another study from webmd and out of one
to a hundred mushrooms is the lowest
with a five wow bring that uh let's well
let's listen i mean it kind of makes
like when you're on mushrooms you know
you don't you're not attacking yeah
you're not you're not aggressive you're
not attacking anybody generally
there's no crime there's no mushrooms
are really easy to acquire just by um
i can never find them when i wanted to
[Laughter]
back in the day yeah i mean you can you
can get them relatively easily you can
grow them really go out go out i want to
see this whole thing
let's see alcohol heroin crack meth
cocaine tobacco way up there not that
bad though actually at the same time
like it's not
you know expect tobacco would be worse
but hey it's not that bad
even harm to self you would expect
[Music]
marijuana is kind of similar to to
tobacco it's a little less harmful but
what's ghp is that like
[Music]
okay what is that no no ketamine keto
means its own thing what the [ __ ] is ghp
uh isn't ghb like the uh the date r drug
oh which in which case i'm a little
confused hey it's uh
why is it so no harm to others it seems
yes flipped i would say this well i
think clearly people are not using it
for that purpose primarily it's supposed
to help with narcolepsy
oh okay well
benzos are pretty low i hear a lot about
the ketamine meth
is the clout pill on there yeah i again
because this is 2010 and in the uk what
the hell is that
is that just lighter feel of
well that is one thing that butane is
what do you do with butane
that's that's some advanced drug use
right there i don't know
that's crazy
i don't know a lot of i mean
cat i don't know what cat is either
that's some new [ __ ] i've never heard of
cat urine clc
butane is hash oil
oh okay that why do they call it that
why are they so slick why they still
like street smart on this just say hash
oil butane yeah like dabs okay
i don't know why this is they separate
that from marijuana they're like this is
better it's better to dab they say uh
dab it up some people are saying that
ghb is also a party drug yeah it has to
be i don't think okay
experts say dab it up
[Laughter]
uh alcohol more harmful than crack or
heroin yeah
here's basically it says the same exact
thing here on this one
but alcohol is like way tops the chart
72 i guess on a scale of 100 whereas
heroin is 55.
that's really
incredible yeah i mean i think the
combination of just how widespread its
use is because it's legal and socially
acceptable to do
you know leads to a lot more people
being exposed to the to the downside
this is the exact same list by the way
it's it's identical i imagine they're
all pulling from the same study yeah
interesting though regardless anyway the
quartering speaking of um
[Applause]
the quartering so this is what he tweets
directly after his interview with her i
told and he tags her gina carrara
i had to adjust my camera as to avoid
having her feet appear on wiki feet her
reply was to put them right on camera
now that's fan service
can't wait for you all to see this
conversation
a smart move imagine you just were a
guest on someone's show
and they tweeting that [ __ ] out but
that's not all that's not where it ended
my friends
uh he continues
corsi does
i'm happy to report
that according to and once again tagging
her to make it even creepier
gina carano my hugging skills were 100
improved
all that practice in front of the mirror
worked and there's even video evidence
you'll have to wait just a little bit
due to embargo but it's some great stuff
and with this
gif of kip
wait it's not over folks
really
yeah if brie larson was ever on a show i
mean obviously not but like it would
just be him just being like i finished i
just i finished
here i was touching myself under the
desk the whole time
and adding her i honestly don't think
you could find another channel that
praises brie larson as much as me
here uh is him saying once again i think
i left my 400 prescription sunglasses
and gina carrero's trailer
now we wait
costanza
that that's a reference to this episode
of seinfeld where george had this theory
that uh good t i can't criticize his
taste in sitcom
i'll say that
we like the same show
yeah george had this theory that the
best way to get keep yourself in a
woman's life who doesn't want you
specifically is to leave [ __ ] in her
apartment so you had a reason to go back
isn't he married jeremy
yes
that he is
maybe his wife's out for pizza or
something yeah maybe that explains why
she's always going well for pizza
without him
this is pretty pretty uh
wild [ __ ] man
even as a joke i guess you'd probably
say it was but
he was too embarrassed to tag her on
this one by the way
can't give away the game
right
exactly
yeah so there's the quartering being an
absolute freak show oh oh she responded
she responded on twitter a few times
anything good
i
sort of just memes and hearts she's
trying to play it off like she's not
terrified
let's see
so
oh wait see i missed this one so at gina
carano
said i have a step-dad hug
exactly she's clearly trying to put the
boundaries on this guy you have a
step-dad hug
that's bad right
and he says so i'm crushed god he's such
a freak show you can't be thirst
trapping her like this you you she's a
guest be respectful
she says amazing that's it
she's trying to be cool about the
god help us all
i'm already taking my pants off
this is just horrific bro
yeah her twitter's a is a nightmare of
like q anon mega freak show too
oh my god
such a nightmare
and despite all that
none of that is as bad as her acting on
the mandalorian
he thought she was bad i don't remember
i [ __ ] hate that character
i don't hate the character but i thought
she was quite bad
also
he liked this post by the way of someone
with a
by the way just a comment the stara dave
the nazi jewish swag oh beautiful it
says unvaccinated so co-signed there
but also he liked that this picture of
him
i mean dude have some respect for
yourself you're married this is a guest
on your show this is just
a trifecta of it you like this tweet
freak yeah you like this that's awesome
it's a freak show that's four likes he's
one of them he is an absolute degenerate
freak show
oh my god a little came out
this guy
just
imagine
who his
average audience must be like who like
the person that watches his videos that
looks exactly like him
undoubtedly a bunch of more
jeremy's
let me look at his channel and see what
he's been up to
a bunch of other people that shoot their
pants in walmart
wearing flannels
no one's got crotch like him though
yo did you guys know that the the latest
thing in like conspiracy land is they
all think walmarts are secretly fema
camps and they're they'll be where like
all of the unvaccinated people get
rounded up and like thrown in the gas
chamber and [ __ ]
oh i just discovered this yes they think
that so there's like a genocide of
unvaccinated coming yes and while there
is you know what it's called covet right
exactly but and and walmart is where
it's all going to be taking place
they're they're all like turning on
walmart walmart's part of the deep state
and walmart is going to be
for walmart where are the concentration
camps
no we're on your team we've been
underpaying and exploiting work and
[ __ ] you know
paying off uh politicians to sim for
corporations for decades it's [ __ ]
awesome we're on your team
imagine clicking one of these videos
we
are we are walmart
this is on the loudspeakers
as the chamber doors close
there's no escape oh the chat's saying
that's uh
that's that conspiracy has been around
for a while well sorry i just learned
about it
dude what the [ __ ] bro you think our
thumbnails are bad
[Laughter]
this is such a wild show
shout out uh recordering i guess
let's get let's take a caller
okay
wait aft after hooking up with boyfriend
his mother used
to clean up towel oh no
brittany what have you done
um i this is such a confession just let
me tell you right away and it's funny
that you guys were talking about uh
magic mushrooms because
that was the night me and my boyfriend
decided to take some and
something happened
what happened what happened
okay so you know we've got a little
freaky you know as couples do on
mushrooms and he
yes that mushroom is that a common thing
to do on mushrooms
everybody's experience is going to be
different i personally
have no interest in anything uh like
that when i'm on mushrooms but okay
interesting your mileage might be the
call of nature happens and one way or
another no judgment obviously
you know you know so after we were done
you know you got to get the the towel
the apparatus to clean up
and so use the towel from the bathroom
and he worked third shift so
um his mom woke up at like six seven in
the morning
and
his dumb ass puts a towel back
where it was by the sink right so i'm
putting on my shoes to get ready to go
and we hear the sink turn on
and all of a sudden we hear his mom like
washing her face
and there's only a towel right next to
the sink you know that only that one
towel
so immediately we realized what we did
and ran the [ __ ] out of there and
yeah that's my confession
okay so let me so there's one bathroom
and one towel in the place
a secondary bathroom in um
like the living room area so she like
came down there to like get ready for
work wow
so so he is terrific so he he used the
towel this is his mom right yeah
yes this is his mom he puts it back and
and did you confirm that the towel was
used on her face or you guys just bailed
it was a pretty uh hard confirmation
when we heard her um
using the water and going
and drying right and there's there's
only one towel now tell me was it like a
hand towel a towel down there what's it
like
what was it a small hand towel or like a
big body towel
it was a small hand towel oh god
oh my god what is the hanging it back up
well okay after the shrooms were
involved i guess judgment may have been
impaired i was like dude are you okay
you're messing with me okay
but it's his own mom for christ's sake
that's a wild one
tastes good i said it was like a full
circle moment you know what i mean like
and was it like that moment i'm sorry
this is disgusting but i'm good i just
have to ask so i apologize
was it a how what was the size of the
load i was talking
oh no i mean
it was a substantial amount you know
what i mean enough to
leave an impact on the towel i guess
like it wasn't just a little splooge it
was like
don't they say it's good for skin
maybe maybe dinner
and and was there any follow-up
information uh did anything come of this
uh something
did you no we kind of just like forgot
about it never talked about it again um
he bought he felt so bad because he
thought his mom was gonna you know find
out that he dropped me off and then he
bought her mcdonald's and said
good morning
he came back with mcdonald's
yes well that's so bad that's like a
giveaway though she doesn't know she
still doesn't know she still doesn't
know oh because i feel like you could
smell it you could feel it there's just
you know i just feel like people like
seaman it's better she doesn't know
clearly obviously it's but it's much
better
that's what i'm saying but it feels good
to get this off my chest so thank you
guys for listening to my confession
thank you for sharing it you know i
that's one of my favorites the towel to
get it off your chest did you guys throw
the towel away eventually or did what
happened yes he did actually like after
that he like took the towel out of the
bathroom yeah because that towel is just
gonna bring back bad memories uh
every time you see it it's like trigger
that's one of my fears is now i'm going
to be having two sons and you know i
know that young boys coming of age just
they just splooge everywhere and i know
there's going to be a time where
everything's just going to be crusty and
[ __ ] up no no no and i'm just i'm
afraid i'm afraid that that day i mean
it's gonna happen i'm just saying you're
gonna find socks
and pillowcases watch out there's gonna
be yellow stains everywhere
i know it's going to happen
i guess it's inevitable isn't it
all right yeah thank you guys and are
you guys still together
yes we are and so how you see his mom
pretty frequently
oh yeah
how long ago did this happen
um i want to say about three years ago
two and a half okay so it's been it's
been a minute
it's probably time to tell her then
do you want me to
drink her on
yeah
can we
get a three-way call going yeah let's
get her on the phone please
no oh my god
no take that to your grave what are you
talking about take that to your grave
don't ever let her know that that
happened obviously
okay okay
i'm glad it's not your fault it's not
your fault
okay i just you know i just when i tell
get a little worked up you know
it's not your fault your boyfriend
should have had a
a towel there or something you got to be
prepared he doesn't have tissue in his
room like why are you going to use that
yeah and if you do i mean that goes
straight to the bottom of the hamper or
like you know what i mean just grab a
t-shirt or something man yeah but to put
it back right but i
i think the magic mushrooms on mushrooms
or not
so
i don't know
all right i hope you guys learned your
lessons from that and you're more
prepared going forward for anything like
that to happen okay it's not your fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
okay
brittany thank you so much
it's not your fault
okay
all right thanks for sharing
we appreciate you all right you take
care
god bless you god bless you both and i'm
happy you guys are still together we we
stan a uh
good couple
i mean listen
it's not your fault britney
no you're not listening to me
it's not your fault
uh ex-boyfriend was a fan of keemstar
um found out his mother
had a shrine
wait what the [ __ ] let me read this
again
ex-boyfriend was a fan of keemstar
and she found out
from his mother that he had a shrine
dedicated to her
with 15 years worth of stuff oh my god
but this is not related to keemstar
does sound interesting though
[Laughter]
let's hear it
from anonymous that's how you know it's
good
i'm surprised britney gave us her name
all right anonymous so
uh hi there how are you today i am
interested uh
what you have the story i'm i've been
ready for weeks now to share the story
with you guys okay good i'm glad we got
you on
all right are you ready for this
ready
okay so when i was about 11 years old i
moved to my aunt's house and uh
to a new school
um
my
later on boyfriend all i'm just going to
call him
dj um he befriends me
and then he starts getting really really
weird like trying to hold my bag for me
to class
just
passing these strange notes
wait hold on hold on i would
yeah yeah you're saying he's your
boyfriend
he later on in the story not yet this is
when she first yeah well what's weird
about holding your bag and that sounds
sweet it sounds like he's trying to be a
good guy oh yeah no it it starts out
very platonic very sweet and just starts
getting a little like more and more
crazy like i um
i was giving all the girls in my class
invitations to my birthday party because
my aunt didn't like having like boys to
the house
so he fished out the invitation from the
trash one of these girls and uh
he he shows up to my house
unannounced as if having the invitation
is at instant access like you guys have
no agency
to turn them away
right right and he he did demand to come
into the birthday and we had to explain
to him that you know it's girls only
party sorry
anyway he starts calling me like crazy
she would call me in the middle of the
night and hang up
hold on hold on hold on let me
this is before you guys dated
this is before i know i know i i feel
like there's
a minute
some red flags i know
for sure and it keeps getting worse and
i was an insecure
11 12 year old girl oh wow okay so that
that yeah
we can't blame we can't blame you
actually
yeah
what i said i couldn't blame an 11 or 12
year old girlfriend for anything she did
uh no judgment at all and uh god bless
you
looking back
definitely red flags but you're 11.
there's nothing wrong so
my teacher ended up finding a whole
thing of letters in his desk like love
letters for weeks and weeks of him
writing these things and the school
actually ended up following a
restraining order against me him
to
not talk to me at school
so during like lunch and recess he
wasn't allowed to talk to me yeah
uh can i ask you something
what was in those yeah yeah i feel like
if there wasn't anything really freaking
those love letters they wouldn't have
done that right
exactly dude they never told me because
i was
little
right
because to this day i don't know what
was in those there must have been
something really
scary in those for them too
yeah
seeing now where it went definitely um
so um
i end up moving to my dad's house which
is about an hour away from from where
this school was and
three years go by we didn't really talk
much
and then
all of a sudden he messaged me on
facebook
and all of my old friends weren't really
messaging me or wanting to talk anymore
and it kind of gave me nostalgia of home
so i
responded back and we started talking
and he was really cool he was really
sweet to me and i started catching
feelings for him
yeah
so then i moved back to my mom's house
kind of for him so that i could go to
school with him and have have more of a
relationship than long distance
um
so
he started
you know 15 year olds
start smoking pot start drinking start
you know acting out and everything
well i would do the same
i started getting in trouble
and
trying to fit in with him and his
friends and it just it wasn't me
um
he
he he would make me sit down and watch
keemstar videos
like the halo 3 oh i know so obnoxious
we would just be laying on his bed
watching
hours and hours of keemstar and halo 3.
oh yeah
wow
keemstar since 2009 or 10.
but um
so
uh he just started getting crazier and
crazier he started writing the list of
people in school he um
he
i don't know if i'm allowed to say this
just use it use a euphemism speak in
code okay
um he he had a list of people that did
me and him wrong
and that he wanted to do something to
them
exactly no freaking way dude yeah
yeah and you knew about this list i'm
real scared
oh i knew about this list and i told the
administrators at school because it
really scared me because he his brother
and him would go hunting and so there
was
hold on let me reflect here for a second
key star
school lists of people hunting
keemstar alone is a red flag but
everything else in combination really
puts it into perspective
man um what did people what kind of
stuff did people do to you guys to land
you on that list
oh it was just like you know just
regular high school stuff saying oh you
know
um your girlfriend
is a is a [ __ ] or you know just just
dumb kid stuff right nothing crazy
really doesn't
no
no and like i had one of my friends
trying to get closer to me and he wanted
to be my boyfriend instead and
that was
not okay so yeah he
it was
did he it was terrible did he
specifically say that he wanted to like
unalive people in the list
oh yeah i mean the top like like it was
like an essay like at the top of this
list was
people i would like to
wow
yeah
that is freaky so how did you find the
list did he show it to you or did you
find it by accident yeah oh he thought i
was like in on this with him oh man like
yeah he would he would tell me all like
just all sorts of crazy stuff and i
never thought it was okay and then and
then this was definitely the last straw
because this is never something to joke
about
um so
i um
i ended up trying to break up with him
and he
there's this really busy street in the
area that i grew up at it's like 50
miles an hour and i was getting on the
city bus to go back home and he kept
trying to
get in front of cars because of me
wanting to break up with him so
he was crying
and just i mean just relentlessly
wanting to stay together and kept saying
he wanted to hurt himself if i would
leave him
um
so
how did the school administrators
respond to the
you telling them about that list you
found
so they ended up expelling him
and then you broke up with him
yeah so i broke up with him and then
like a few weeks later
they had like a a huge meeting with all
of his teachers
and the counselors at school and like
the dean and everything um
and
they they decided to fully expel him
because that just no tolerance policy
whatsoever did the police ever
run amok yes i know another good what
would we be without men
who keep notes of other enemies
the police did end up getting like kind
of like a um
oh shoot i forgot to tell you guys he
tried to also light a kindergarten our
preschool center on fire too while we
were dating
and you stayed with them after that one
he's a kid
too
dude's a go-getter
what do we do without men
trying to burn down kindergartens
being a keemstar fan was ethan on that
list
oh god oh god
shut up baby i hate myself for saying
all this out loud now like it was this
is all like you're a young girl there's
no blame it's not your fault i'm married
now with kids and and have gone and
experienced life and it's just so cringy
to me that like i let any of this [ __ ]
happen let me ask you though i i
understand you're a young girl so i'm
not judging you but
i'm just fascinated by the whole thing
when your boyfriend tries to burn down a
kindergarten how do you rationalize that
uh well he explained to me that it was
like late at night and he had snuck out
at home and he went to go pick up some
some weed
and that he was uh
he met his dealer at a the
preschool center
in the parking lot
yeah perfect right yeah and uh he he
said he was trying to light his joints
and that's why the fire started
wow
didn't someone else start a fire
yeah maybe he was just falling in the
footsteps
you know that just sounds to me
that just sounds to me like a guy who
full sins
yeah also it sounds like this was at
night so there was no kids there so i
don't really see the problem with
burning down the school oh so it's a
habit if it's an empty what are we gonna
do without men i mean who gives a [ __ ]
trying to
i'm gonna go rip a dart
yo actually um well that's funny because
i you know i go to chuck e cheese uh
inside to meet my dealer we meet in the
ball pit oh right
absolutely that's the best thing but
after they're closed right because then
that'd be one during
oh ethan
daring you gotta
you gotta wait after 8 p.m when they
walk up to that kind of show
thing they never suspect it like no no
that's where i buy my black tar heroine
is in the ball pit of chuck e cheese
wow what a character uh so okay proceed
so he tried to burn down to elementary
school we love that
love it so um
we're broken up at this point i've
gotten
completely blocked on all you know i
think it was just like instagram and
facebook at that point there wasn't any
crazy
other social medias haven't blocked on
my phone
and uh my best friend lived down the
street from our high school and uh
wow
sorry couple days
no you're fine
um a few weeks later we would see him
hiding in between the cars across the
street from her house to try to get a
peek of me and and to talk to me
and i ended up yeah i ended up having to
call his mom and his mom actually took
him away to his brother's house which is
like
uh three hours south of where we are so
i
i didn't hear from him again
until after high school
this it this gets a little wild too
we're here for it
so
so um he's really good friends with my
cousin
um and my cousin's trans
um she had not transitioned yet at this
point though
so um she and him were hanging out in
the living room and i was at my aunt's
house hanging out with them
and he just kept begging me to get back
together with him even though he'd been
like two or three years he had changed
that he would never do anything like
that ever again and
i smartened up at this point was like oh
hell no dude you can kick the curb i
don't know why you're even in this house
my cousin should never be friends with
you you're psycho
so i'm laying there and i start falling
asleep
and then i like hear something and i'm
like what is that noise
and i kind of open my eyes a little bit
and i hear
dj
say
is it gay if i come
is it
what does that mean
what's
right next to me yep yo
yeah yeah and i just kind of lay there
just i mean paralyzed
your cousin what's up with your cousin
man that's some that's some wild [ __ ]
right there
well
i later asked her why she did what she
did and she said well i just wanted to
see if i could
um
that explains a lot of my hookups
you know um did did your cousin answer
his question
oh she said no it wasn't it's not gay
okay fair enough no it was quite clearly
it wasn't gay so
i mean i yeah
well i don't i don't i don't think it's
gay to have sex with the trans woman
right i mean we've well she wasn't trans
i was about to say she said
hadn't transitioned at that point oh
so he was having sex with a dude
a man right you're ugly right i think
that is gay i think it might be that's
gay
it would technically at that time be be
gay hold on let's ask that you've gone
in uh preacher so who is gay
he would be both of them technically you
are transgender he wasn't yet not yet
yeah well i mean they could still be
transgender without yet transitioning
that's true he may that's true that's
complicated it is complicated it is
complicated
she didn't know she was trans yet so she
did identify as a male at the time okay
okay so no i think it's definitively gay
at that point
i think it is yeah yeah i i have to
agree but
definitely gay so what was this what was
the act they were in uh were they just
um fellatio
and did you did you ever like open your
eyes a
slit and see what was going on
just the hair but i have gone through
therapy to try to remove it from my
brain oh my god so i believe it's
somewhere there but it doesn't exist
right now
and i got news for you i'm sorry for
bringing that okay yeah i think that oh
no no it's fine i'm i'm divulging all
this okay so and the possibility has
crossed your mind clearly that he's not
gay at all and just wanted to get in the
same room as you
that is exactly correct he wanted to get
on good graces with my cousin so that i
would get back together with him but
also not just that the act of having sex
in the same room as you
even if it's with right a man and he's
not gay
this is this is yeah i don't know what
the strategy was there
to win her back my cousin was my best
friend at the time so i figured i guess
if he
let him do i i don't know
yeah
um this guy is
i think a danger to society man this
guy's scared
oh yeah so that now he's an adult
so i actually have uh some of his
charges written down on my phone right
now he uh
he stole his mom's car when he was 19
totaled it
he then later goes to jail for assault
and
of course possession of i believe
cocaine and marijuana
and then he actually broke into his
mom's house while his mom and stepdad
were in colorado
and i ended up doing i got i believe
about two or three years for that
is he in jail currently um
i don't know he's totally a ghost on
social media
i've been trying to
figure out if he's in but the state of
california is really hard to figure out
who's in prison or jail
um
so what happened so so anyway from the
cousin incident what happens from there
so i don't talk to him for years
and um i mean
by the way let me ask you
i'm just i'm curious about this
situation you're in the bed you're
pretending to be asleep how long did
that go on for and then what how did it
end
i'm on the couch
so it was this living room and there's
one couch on one end of the room and one
couch on the other and they both face
each other okay i'm lying on one crouch
and they're lying on the other couch
and i've fallen asleep i believe
and all
they weren't really talking and i
believe i dozed off and then i woke up
to hear dj say that to my cousin
and then
they walked outside and
had cigarettes or
i don't know
and that was
the next morning i asked my cousin
uh
what had happened and she clearly said
oh yeah you know he he let me do that in
hopes
of
rekindling with you
bro what is the logic there
[Music]
that is wild logic
oh
man
all right so what happens i'm curious i
want to hear where the story goes
yeah so um
i also have to comment right currently
his profile picture is him holding hands
with his lawyer getting out of jail for
his assault charge
oh yeah what a good lawyer
we did it
your lawyer ever
doesn't sound like a very good lawyer
i'll hold his hand once we once we win
this
the trailer suit yeah okay i'll go skip
down the street them oh yeah
so
this is where it gets real wild for me
this part of the story
this was only a few weeks ago for me
i am grocery shopping with my daughter
and my newborn son
and i see his mom and his mom is a
really sweet lady and so she stops and
we chat a little bit and
i notice she has a really weird look on
her face and i haven't seen her since me
and him were boyfriend and girlfriend so
it's been
10 years
did she wait did she ever use a kami
towel
that was uh that was the other
caller well he had a [ __ ] blanket so i
mean i guess that's
you know
yeah but did she wipe her face with it
wait you come on your mom wait whoa whoa
whoa
you came on your mom's
blanket oh no he did he did he came on
your mom's blanket yeah
not my mom's his own mother's
with you and
why did he do that oh no no not with me
involved he would go in her room and
like do it what and he told you that
they're you know i'm so sorry there's so
many elements to this guys
all day long i know this is like i've
been trying to condense it but there's
so much average king star viewer
i love that this guy's a keemstar viewer
that's the best thing ever
that's the best thing of this story yo
this guy's a literal case study from
that show on netflix was it called where
he studies like serial killers
yeah
i'm blinking right now my mind minefield
mine hunter
mine hunters
yeah something so he would just go in
his mom's room and come on her blanket
for no reason
she said it was really soft her like her
blanket in there was really soft oh okay
so
yeah you know
can you imagine you're just sleeping in
a pool of your own
[Laughter]
whatever his mom tells you in the
grocery store you should have told her
about the jizz blanket as a revenge
but go ahead
what she ended up finding out
she found out about that
yeah how'd she find out about that
well she
kept noticing
crunchy songs yeah exactly
oh jesus and so you were there for all
of this huh so tell me what happened
with that how did the mom find out what
happened
of the blanket situation yes
well she we
we came home from school one day and
this was at the end of our relationship
i mean it i was like
i was counting ways to escape it at this
point and so she comes in and she says
like
what why is there you know why has there
been these like spots on my blanket and
um because he he would do it in his own
room blankets but he preferred hers
because it was softer so she said you
know i there's there's these spots on
your blanket and spots on mine and i
think we both know what it is and this
is just absolutely unacceptable
and just walked away
oh jesus was he embarrassed or just like
whatever [ __ ] you mom
put her on the list whatever [ __ ]
and laughed so yes
great
all right we're back in the grocery
store what did his mom tell you
so she gets to start to get a really
weird look on her face after we like
kind of catch up with each other
he has a kid at this point too with this
other girl named um
emily
um lucky ladies and gentlemen
yep lucky lucky and uh she's telling me
how the you know how her granddaughter
is and everything she sees my kids and
we're talking
gets a really weird look on her face and
says
i don't know if you know this and i said
no what like there's a lot to know
and she said well
um
about two or three years after you guys
broke up
i found a lot of stuff like under his
bed and in his closet
i'm like okay well
what do you mean by that
and um
she said
that she found
my the old invitation for my sixth grade
party
he
this is probably dipping into a line
that we can cross on uh
on live but
she found videos of things that we would
do that i did not know he was filming
you didn't know that
yes yes yikes
yes
um
i didn't know okay continue before i get
before i react wow yeah yeah
wow i um
baggies of my used gum that had the
dates on them
my feminine
oh save that low feminine products
use feminine products
use feminine products
my old underwear
um i had a few ipods that went missing i
just assumed that they got stolen at
school but there was two of my old ipods
there
my old phone and some lip gloss
and
he
at some point probably broke into my old
house because we kept a spare key under
the mat
so
maybe when we were out of town on one of
the camping trips that we would go on
all the time he probably came into my
house and took some of my things because
my old phone i never took my old phone
anywhere with me it was just in a drawer
um and yeah there was just stuff that he
i never really
gave him access to while we were
together
um
so
yeah so it was all like laid out why the
[ __ ] would she tell you this
at all wait what what was her reason for
telling you this did you hit the x love
yeah i improvised what
wait you're exiting this love
yeah it's too long
am i what wait love just x you
oh with peace and love of course why
he says it's too i don't know
i have a short attention span
you still have you're still on a
lifeline love extra dan
evie did that everyone saw that no that
was you love love
no no i haven't listened to anything oh
happy birthday by the way the last 10
minutes did too
that was that hitting my button
okay well did so was that a legit x or
no i'm just gonna i'm just gonna was it
legit exactly hold on hold on one sec
was that a legit x uh i'm sorry this
story is just too long huh
i was interested i think it's great i'm
i'm always
yeah it's a good story i just
i don't know i lost all the attention
yeah it's my fault it's my fault it is
it's not your fault yeah
we get a really great caller and here we
are dropping x's like uh
candy well you zoom in no [ __ ] it's
it's the zoomers on the staff
you guys want to argue about who's a
zoomer this is more entertaining than
this woman's uh harrowing story where
would we be without men stealing use
tampons
[Laughter]
where would we be without men taking gum
and putting it in bags and sealing them
and writing down the dates
i feel i feel bad for this person like i
i'm not that bad you dropped an ex i
feel bad i feel bad for you but
like this dude sounds like a [ __ ]
knuckle
why the [ __ ] just one question
why did she tell you that what was her
reason for telling you there at that
time in the grocery store that part
doesn't make any she thought i should
genuinely know because she was so
weirded out by the situation that she
thought that i should just know that
have that knowledge now your life may be
in danger like unironically if this is
all true
i i haven't heard from him
like from himself in years
well thank you for calling in i loved it
all i thought it was fascinating but the
crew here has other ideas so
according to the rules thank you guys
according to the rules engagement i have
to drop you but i thank you so much for
calling in
i appreciate your time thank you i loved
it i thought it was awesome thanks for
sharing your story i love you also can i
say one more thing please
i'm actually wearing hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on
before you say it
before you say it
because we do have an x situation here
love is she permitted to finish her
thought no i mean she only has two exes
it was a nomination and a second yeah
can she proceed
yeah of course yeah yeah and zach can
she proceed for teddy fresh
i bought my first teddy fresh sweatshirt
and it's the only you
uh smokey the bear and i just have to
say i am absolutely in love with it
thank you so much thank you i love that
thank you thank you build a shrine to it
put it under your bed i loved it thanks
for sharing stay safe that guy is like a
no joke man yeah that guy's a real
psychiatrist
thank you guys
yeah stay safe sorry you've been through
all that that's pretty wild we've always
wondered who watches dramaalert take
care character take care love you bye
thank you yeah i mean
the biggest takeaway
drama alert fan that's a dramaalert
nation that's what that's what your
brain on drama alert
people were saying they thought the chat
is always so wild they think she was
lying i mean no way she was lying right
no that's all real as it gets yeah i
didn't really get i
unfortunately
those guys are out there
his name is daniel keem
[Laughter]
the chat is split on if we
hm well anyway i'm confused doesn't she
need three x's to be no two no the rules
always been two not america's got talent
giving love and acts
yeah where the [ __ ] you get that did you
get that
did you give yourself an ex love
kevin sent it to me wait look cam just
gave himself an x
wow
if you did that everyone saw that
yeah that was 100 real
well we got the story i was fascinated i
mean i loved that [ __ ] the story was
great it was just so long
it just kept drawing and she kept saying
oh this is the wildest part
she kept i was asking her the questions
that was making it longer it was all
wild but she's like oh this is the
wildest part oh it's the wildest part
it's all wild
you're such a dick
amy's learned to just sit back
i'm just playing oh yeah yeah i've i
used to hit the button first all the
time and then i got a bunch of [ __ ] from
the chat now i love watching them suffer
i just sit here smile looking at people
say move on
what do people want to pull for if they
liked the call or thought it was too
long i'm going to do a pull
let's do a pull
you want to pull what what's the poll
what's that if people liked the call or
didn't or didn't like the call you know
i'm just curious i'm trying to
understand how to make an entertaining
show here i personally was fascinated i
loved her i thought she was a great
storyteller on top of it some people are
way longer winded than that she was
getting to the point there was always
new stuff going on i'm just happy it
wasn't about [ __ ]
yeah we've we've scaled back our [ __ ]
yeah our [ __ ] calls we've taken enough
so the the pole is just was it a good
call
all right pulls up roll it here we go
all right here let's go to the pole
the pull is
okay well we've got an overwhelming
mostly good seventy percent and second
place is good but too long
nobody look
this is uh
okay
interesting
well
hey listen
uh nobody gets these kind of numbers so
shout out to the caller
you did a fantastic job we love you
sharing your story with us that's a 65
i mean presidents don't even get
approval i don't know what's happening
i'm trying to show the damn here it is
uh that's a approval rating like
unprecedented for a call
so thank you thank you peace and love oh
you did
um cam just discovered he dropped it in
discord a uh new um horrible marvel
audio edit just throw away
with our boy jared leto no way
i haven't listened to this yet cam said
it's
the best one
just
to refresh the audience marvel has this
habit of doing doo-doo
sound edits that sound just absolutely
horrible and this is the first time for
me in the marvel universe
so funny hi my name is
[Music]
you know what's funny
that's pretty similar to the ones they
did yeah pretty much it's not that
different all right so we got a new one
with jared leto
oh the audio's off
um can you time stamp it so i don't have
to watch this whole thing you get
claimed
oh
first person okay
morbius is a marvel character who's been
an important part of the universe
that one
morpheus is a
wait let's try it again
morpheus is a marvel character who's
morbius is a marvel character
hang on an important part of the
universe
it's awesome dude
why is jared little being put in though
why no less jared leto we don't need
jared leto and more stuff well i'm
seeing that this is
see this shit's getting confusing
because this is this is actually a sony
movie
not like it is a marvel character
i guess it's part of the series with
venom like the tom hardy venom movie and
uh
not great tracker carnage movie and uh
and now this morbius movie evidently
i love that the studios are doing like
the spider-verse so they could share
rights now they cross them over that way
yeah it's getting
too unwieldy i can't keep up
this is the first time for me in the
marvel universe oh that was amazing you
picked up right where it was
so we got channel five uh we have to
talk about pete davidson and
and kim kardashian which is totally
unacceptable
the channel 5 video is pretty long
let's just do kim and then we can get
into channel 5.
yeah so kim kardashian obviously just
went through a divorce
with uh
kanye west
um and well this all started with a kiss
where all good romances begin it started
with a kiss
i didn't watch this [ __ ] i don't really
care about saturday night live pete
davidson or kim kardashian i'm cool like
that
got him
round of applause
very brave but thank you but uh
regardless uh here it is yet here i am
talking about it on my show
i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
[Applause]
move over king of uganda oh no he didn't
give me balls
so
great stuff not funny obviously the
show's never funny it's honestly
horrible i'm sorry i know people like it
i who likes internet live other than
boomers like our parents
i
i think a lot of people
and
still gets
good ratings and stuff i think
at least it was the last few years i
don't know how it's doing does anyone in
this building watch saturday night live
no i have not watched it in a long time
i used to watch it
i used to watch it uh
every week growing up mm-hmm and re-runs
on the community yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like boomers
because your parents would put it on
yeah i used to watch it with my grandma
exactly your grandmother
i mean i used to watch the chris farley
reruns and [ __ ] i mean that was thank
you exactly but this new [ __ ] it's gotta
go man
must be stopped it's it's just bad well
i did anyway i did see in the headlines
that um
that they kissed and everyone was
talking about it
i guess because she was just recently
divorced and everyone's gossiping about
pete davidson
and all that well apparently
uh it was all it began with a kiss
olivia's won't put in a note here she
said i called it
olivia really wants credit for this so i
i think is she downstairs or upstairs uh
she's upstairs right now i'll just i'll
read her no she said i called it
i said it felt misplaced and that the
kiss was unnecessary to the sketch so
one of them clearly wanted to add it so
olivia is
saying she 100 called this
she did i can confirm
she she called this she did call this
yes really and she said she thinks
they're they're
doing it yeah she's like doing it
like she's like i said that and i no one
answered and she like specifically
pointed she's like you remember right
i'm like yeah i remember do you remember
are you lying first i remember okay just
saying just saying
on friday night the two were spotted at
not scary farm with a group of friends
photos depict kim and pete holding hands
on a roller coaster
and sitting next to each other
which as my notes say is pretty crazy
quote end quote
it says that in the dog you guys want to
see
literally i believe you yeah thank you
uh so
i'm assuming what happened was like some
other writer just took a photo of this
and no that looks like it's the [ __ ]
the one that's the written
uh
so they so that means that they leaked
it to the press
yeah i mean probably
it says people exclusive photo if this
is the photo it could be a disney
employee too
or whatever not disney sorry don't sue
me disney the farm place
knott's berry
is that what it was yes that's very far
yeah a knott's berry employee
can you not technically buy any photo on
there
you don't have to be the person in the
photo ah that's pretty weird that makes
sense that's yeah no that's an
interesting question i don't think they
would sell you other people's photos i
[ __ ] hope not they probably just
leaked it themselves yeah they
kim knows how to play the boss
that's what this is i think she is
trying to show herself as an eligible
hot young lady she's back on the market
she knows how to play the media and pete
my boy
uh
okay i don't know if you could call it
being used because you can't use the
willing right
but uh
isn't there a pretty significant age gap
between them he is 27 and she is 40
something let me double check
it's age gap but at 27 i i'm not really
oh i'm not saying that i'm not i'm not
just curious and you know it's 20
where would you say the age gap where
you could be like oh that's
what's in your late twenties
whoever you want yeah yeah in my opinion
i mean you could date whoever you want
your brain's developed you're an adult
you can make your own choice maybe 25
plus
something like that yeah i guess it
depends on the person 24 seems odd pete
davidson is a
successful
adult he can make his own decisions
well anyway
this is that kim's a groomer
just kidding
this
this union has to stop this is sick
this is [ __ ] up
this is freak [ __ ]
this is a crime against humanity we
don't stand we don't like this
ironically
ian and i
we
it was pete davidson right that
wasn't it you ran into him at the at the
kanye party
uh those years ago
what a betrayal
was inviting him to his oh
because she's dating king dong now
apparently
he has a big one oh yeah that dude's got
a monster huh okay calm down zach jesus
no you've seen it no ian's like yeah
ariana said he's got like a 12-inch hog
and like 12 inches
he's got a five dollar foot one i heard
yeah i heard her say that
i heard him on howard stern howard kept
asking him about it
a five dollar footlong what the [ __ ]
but uh what do you think do you think
uh kanye is mad about this ian or do you
think he's like whatever because i know
he's out there getting strange ass too
it's yay
yay sorry
strange
what do you think uh uh if he's what mad
yeah well i don't know you know you know
his mind intimately what do you think is
his reaction to this
i do not know
oh come on getting just just you can
take a guess
what is he mad his ex-wife is with
another guy maybe sounds reasonable come
on
dude how many times do we have to do
this every time i don't care about him
anymore
really you're out how many times
well because you i feel like you should
have some insight bro
what would be the ins what would it be
what's the insight here
well i'm not you what are you asking me
i'm not the kanye stan i didn't i didn't
write a i didn't write a screenplay
about his ride what would i just
i don't know
okay you ain't got the answer swag
you could say he's mad he's not mad yeah
he's probably mad
based on what
my my deep understanding of his mind
he's probably pretty mad
how do you what kind of mad like is he
like big man big mad probably like big
man
well i wonder if this is a publicity
thing or she's just trying to [ __ ] with
them you know what i mean or she just
trying to put herself back on the market
well she's been uh going to all of his
shows and still supporting it doesn't
seem like they necessarily have like a
uh
that's true
i mean they're co-parents
i have a theory of a theory the tall
skinny guy is
in right now so you got you know mgk and
uh megan fox all right you got courtney
and travis yeah and you got pete and kim
right what a theory what's called
tall skinny [ __ ] lanky guys nice it's
the end now
i think it's always been in
i love it
i think he's pissed i think he's
he's so pissed he's like you know what
i'm gonna [ __ ] work with triller
right why would that well
i'm gonna make some mistakes i'm gonna
work with triller yeah my judgment is
impaired let's just keep going down this
path baby okay well there you have it uh
from ian himself he says kanye is mad
[Applause]
word on the street i'm gonna get that
tattooed
kanye is mad he insulator
oh god that's pretty amazing though
shout out to pete i guess because this
guy has quite a roster i mean it's
pretty incredible i don't understand it
he like okay he he ended up with ariana
grande before that he was relatively
unknown
he's with ariana grande
cast member yeah i don't know but like
there's plenty of caspers on snl that i
won't even recognize on the street let's
be honest
and he was one of them let's just be
real about it
he dates he dates ariana
huge exposure everywhere
and from there
i guess women love them so i'm not going
to say like one thing or the other
cutie
yeah i mean like
kate beckinsale olivia's obsessed with
them
and i'm not gonna hate i guess he's got
that
cool guy
total skinny big dick dude
everything i'm not
oh yeah i remember he dated larry
david's daughter how weird is that wait
really so cool yeah he was dating her
back before ariana
they dated for a while so if they got
married her last name would be cassie
davidson
it would change
kazzy yeah that's interesting
pete david
we just changed a little bit yeah
andy said she wrote a book about how he
broke her heart i think he dumped her
for ariana
cold-blooded if i was later david i'd be
like you're done in this business you're
done
they moved on to ariana
is this a clout i mean is this a clout
um
this made me wonder if this is a clout
agenda because if you leave
larry david's daughter
for ariana
it seems like a clout move
it makes me suspicious anyway
no
possibly i don't know too many factors
but now he needs the clout i mean he's
famous at this time he definitely needed
the clout this was his move this was the
big move right here from this to this
here normal guy
here
superstar household name
so i might invent the clout pill the
real question is when did he fix his
teeth
yeah apparently he had a gap and he got
uh
he got his teeth done
people are saying i'm very comments he
was pretty famous yeah he was pretty
famous but he wasn't like a household
name i'm just saying
he was just some dude on saturday night
live which describes like a thousand
people
what the hell is happening king of
staten island came out after the clout
move you guys
is this intentional love
is love just playing video games playing
some world of warcraft he literally
cares that much about this show
are you trying to say you don't care
i mean that's pretty cool
it's like a jade
okay cool yeah yeah take it for life
thanks bro biggest fan right
yeah so um
he goes from ariana to kate beckinsale
that was a wild one right there boy
who was like 50 plus right and i mean
god bless you she looks amazing but
she is 48. okay
oh i got a message from olivia here she
says
i linked the kiss and their dog kim is
41. that was earlier uh they broke up
after years of dating and he got engaged
like a month later
thank you so you agree olivia that it
was a clout move
they broke up after years and being
engaged to a month later
with freaking
ariana
and then kaya gerber the gerber baby he
dated the gerber baby oh [ __ ] yeah so
we're moving holy [ __ ]
that's the biggest club move of all
right
hold on don't get ahead of yourself
we're moving in the clout the clout
trail
the cloud the trail of clout tears
maybe i shouldn't joke about the uh
native genocide yeah take that back
kyra is cindy crawford's daughter hold
on guys i'm sorry sorry
i don't know who this is but she's
beautiful margaret galley
she was in that movie oh
once a time in hollywood she was the
weird cult girl and her mom is uh andy
mcdowell
okay
um and then this was a big one kaya
gerber
very uh uh
relevant supermodel daughter of uh
and she's the main character in a
netflix series kaya gerber
the gerber baby according to olivia
oh olivia's giving me all the intel kaia
gerber no she said sorry kaya was 18.
it's not maya it's margaret it's uncanny
okay kaya was 18 when this happened well
how old was he
when that happened mid-20s or something
i would imagine if he's 27 now
i don't know it seems like a trail of
clout to me guys i mean it worked he's
holding exactly oh sure for sure he
clouded his way up all the way to kim
kardashian bro that's insane
check me i don't know who this is but
very beautiful phoebe uh
[ __ ]
who is this i don't know just another
actress i guess
anyway all the way up to kim k man
that's that's a wild ride they took so
is that like the top of the the ladder i
think so keep working his way up more no
way
he's gotta hurry up because she's on her
way out
the next thing you know uh the queen of
england and pete davidson caught in a
cafe holding hands
kyrie the kyle the cougar uh
punching here oh yeah yeah yeah
who's the like biggest clown pull pete
caguette i mean kim kardashian yeah you
have a baby with a kardashian you're set
for life yeah alimony for always being
relevant somehow well there's that
there's that kardashian curse thing oh
this girl was
uh phoebe was the lead of bridger i
berger i didn't watch that show but it
was very popular apparently
so olivia can you come down i need your
take on this whole thing uh you're the
expert
i know one down olivia please stand up
she said
she sent me all these notes on discord
but we need her take
this to me is a trail of clouds
and um
well kim kardashian's the ultimate clout
demon so she's obviously knows what
she's getting into he may have met his
match in her
i need that stoppable force meets the
immovable object
but i guess that's what you what happens
when you have good dick is that
you get things in life
but that's what you say you know when
you're when you're beautiful everything
happens for you
because chris rock who said the uglier
you are read the more books read more
books something like that that's all you
got
yeah
this is his next target is the ultimate
clout is that the gerbi baby growing up
sure is uh damn she's fine
boy
all right olivia is this a is this a
trail of clout we're looking at here
we're talking about pete and his road of
conquest to
don't say anything that'll hurt your
chances
right absolutely not never um
oprah's next people are saying
[Laughter]
he's going to find his way onto that old
list if you know what i'm saying oh yeah
i kind of feel like he just
sees the it girl when it's happening and
he probably is like i have a crush on
them and he has access to it
so he shoots a shot you know what i mean
hell yeah brother yo check this out he
was seen holding hands with the [ __ ]
statue of liberty dude oh [ __ ] he's
gonna [ __ ] lady liberty
yeah that's pretty cloudy right there
that's as cloudy as it gets
that's america baby so you don't you
don't think there's any uh there's no uh
objective here i feel like there isn't
he's famous enough isn't he at this
point at this point yes but [ __ ] kim
k
look at that that's crazy i know she's
so lucky
such a simp
i love him
what do you love about him you just
think he's handsome yeah i just think
he's super cute he's swag i thought he
was funny yeah he's pretty swag adele
you like it so tell me about this like
is it just the looks or is it the whole
swag it's like it's all of it you like
the tabs the attitude
he's a little damaged do you like that
as well
[Music]
would you say he's your type i would
so you like boys with tats
you like skinny boys
yeah because what do you think of the
island boys
i straight up before we knew they were
cancelled
i'm gonna have to wear this very
carefully
ethan was joking about flying them out
here and i turned to i think it was like
dan or sam and i was like i s if ethan
flies them out i swear to god i'm going
to fall in love with one of them oh
they're kind of handsome jesus i mean i
mean i don't [ __ ] cancel the list as
a as a gag
they
are the beat her you be swept away man
you would leave them you don't want to
talk about it
off to an island no they're like
an exaggerated exaggerated obnoxious
version of what is typically my type
which i don't like personally that
that's my tag but i hope that that's the
bad thing
you got you got a bad boy
i feel like everybody kind of likes the
bad boy really
yeah
i don't know
i don't know what that like trope is
it's just it's enticing
you know what i mean just a little like
unconventional
a little smelly he goes his own way i
say my i used to say that my type was
like dusty oh see dusty
covered in dust covered in dust
seen better days and showers bleeding
kind of open sores is it is it possibly
that you want to save him in a way
because like
you want to mother him in a way not in
like a weird way but
you know there's a maternal instinct
well he has a mom right now kim
kardashian's uh
making that noise
stop
in pete's defense
he went to a trailer event and he sort
of hosted it and completely [ __ ] on it
oh that was he was an originator i you
know what everything i've said i love
pete for that because
he was the first one to [ __ ] ryan
cavanaugh and i love him for that true
right he [ __ ] ryan kavanagh well
actually no the judge was one of the
first ones to [ __ ] over ryan cavanaugh
for sure oh [ __ ] over oh didn't he
didn't he ask jake paul about his r word
accusations
yeah and then they cut it out
he lampooned the whole thing he was
imitating jake paul on snl like a week
ago
saying that jake paul's next fight's
going to be with muhammad ali
impersonating him
saying there's no way you can hide well
anyway i'm just i'm fascinated you know
uh
i'm fascinated by the
female mind uh clearly yeah i mean i'm
in the majority right for sure yeah i
mean clearly
i will say i did have a crush on him
before ariana started dating him
oh she's stolen from you wow
no okay no we love aria i've always been
i've always maybe i'm just yeah
he's that tall skinny type i think
that's just a type it's a good type
girls like that type
you know yeah
we're all such degenerates in here
amy's handsome but
thanks
do you just call all of us ugly no no
i'm not talking about you
jesus i don't know why i'm talking about
myself i don't know why i threw you on a
nice compliment yeah
and i was certainly not talking about
the women
you know if you could just cut that part
out
just
i like that rewind this whole delete me
from this conversation there you go
anyway [ __ ] all right well there you
have it congratulations pete davidson
for
hopefully maybe we'll even get a sex
tape out of it what do you think
congratulations kim kardashian
i would say uh i see
there's a lot of pressure on that
to perform
well it's also like
machine gun cali megan fox i feel like
kim kardashian and pete davidson are the
step up identical though he's wanting up
being yeah like davidson is the more
famous version of machine gun kelly it
feels like and kim kardashian's the more
famous version of
olivia would you agree with me the trend
mgk
megan fox you got travis barker
kourtney kardashian now kim and pete oh
it's definitely a trend thank you yeah
somebody wants to see you with chet
hanks what do you think about that oh
yeah would you date chat
oh my god let me rethink this
bigger bigger picture
let me ask you this or do you find
machine gun kelly attractive i do yeah
i personally would choose pete davidson
except actually his old tweets and stuff
were gross
you know you don't like guys that want
to [ __ ] 13 year olds
no no i don't okay
but before i was aware of that yeah
that's too bad boy yeah
that's a little too bad that's wally i
thought you liked the bad boy what
happened there's a line there's a line
not that bad
that is so true i'm pretty damn i'm not
that damaged you know what i mean
i'm on antidepressants uh i know he
always talks about how he's on
anti-pressure and maybe that makes me a
bad boy
true
so true
lexapro bad boy i thought about i
thought you were a bad boy for a long
time
i'm a bad boy how do you be a bad boy i
guess you just get tattoos
you're just like you're obnoxious i
think you're a bad boy ethan
[Laughter]
you say it like that i knew you wanted
to [ __ ] me i like you
i know you have a bad wine
wait let's take a poll i actually am
curious do you guys think i'm a bad boy
is ethan a bad boy
what you're rational
okay but you think i'm making a joke but
i'm not
you refuse to wear shoes that's
gangster's [ __ ] you only wear slippers
like i don't care where i'm going yeah
you're not putting on pants for nobody
right that's g as [ __ ] what else
boy what you gonna do
keep going
you be calling people out
true
be serious though guys you know i'm
being i'm making a joke now i'm saying
it but i want people to vote for okay
you do your own thing you can't
i thought this is bad
i just need cats
this just sounds like a lovely doing
your own thing is not the same as being
a bad one
dan you're bad too don't worry about it
you're good
we're getting pretty good results here
55 saying i am a bad boy
[Music]
hmm you think i'm a good boy i think
you're a good boy too
i disagree you yeah
i appreciate no everyone google people
agree with you baby so don't feel bad
thank you
[Music]
okay
well chris brown is a bad boy does that
do anything for you
chris brown i hate chris brown right
beating women i also
am curious
because you like drake don't you
there we go yeah dream
oh never mind no it's great i'm curious
how other people feel about drake
because no one really talks about it bad
boy well he dated rihanna
and then
he collabed with chris brown after they
broke up and no one talks about that bad
boy that's just a that's just that is
the music
wait i didn't know he did that yeah no
one talks about it
that's after the whole incident after he
dated what a [ __ ] scum well they got
they got in a fight in the club about
rihanna if i'm not mistaken they got
like a fist fight and then they
collapsed and then they clapped
i don't know maybe it was like a darth
vader bringing him back to the light
situation drake is not a bad boy he's
just a goofball he is a goofball but he
also did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
i don't like that drizzy on that exo
okay interesting well that was a really
fascinating conversation i appreciate it
at all absolutely
we've got the um
you guys want to play game of is that
racist
um no
no okay i don't think so
i don't know anything other than the
title of the segment but that sounds
like well the tick
dressed up as dora the explorer
for halloween a white girl and she like
tanned super dark
and people are saying it's a big time
called getting called out
yeah let's play is that racist everybody
is that
racist
the new game
from h3 productions
get your polls ready get your beepers
ready this one comes from tick tock
still up by the way calm is disabled
um dora the explorer this is a white
girl by the way
chad's saying this is a bad idea
i'm just showing her
okay
so this is like a straight up white girl
oh that's pretty
yeah she went dark oh that's pretty bad
she went really dark that's worse than i
was expecting
i think i thought people knew by now not
to do this
don't change your skin tone for
costumes i mean is this is this like an
influencer or something yeah she's a yes
oh okay yeah probably shouldn't do that
let's see oh my god stop i don't like
this oh my god where was the
oh my okay here it is
here let's see how many followers she
has oh she's small 20 000.
oh she's really she's still riding it
well that doesn't come off easily right
it's going to be on there so wait let me
find out what she usually
her skin tone looks like she was playing
arabic music in that first video
um
this is her wait that's what oh well
then hold on what is everyone
okay maybe i shouldn't comment on this
that's what i said
okay here i guess is more accurate
okay well let me give some background on
that
i didn't put it in here who did i want
to know
right now
anybody i don't know
uh i mean it was a huge story
yeah i saw it so wait uh people were
angry
here's def's got the scoop let's look at
deaf noodles i'll blame him for it
okay so here's what she looks like so
i guess that's just
that's that's a big difference in skin
tone there girl
yeah
we saw this
oh here here's a reaction to it
couldn't give me the volume for that one
it's muted
[Music]
no i can't i can't do it
hey queen why are you why are you tanner
than my concealer
that's funny for sure
oh my god they're white
no cause we are the same shade
i was confused until i read the comments
yeah
okay that's the whole story guys
and that eyebrow game is pretty
pretty interesting
okay that's the look i'm going for with
the plucking mm-hmm yeah i'm not you
know what i'm doing i'm not gonna vote
i'm not gonna decide
no no no i don't want anyone to make any
nice shot love
first blood thank you oh let's go double
kill yeah
triple kill triple let's go love
yeah this is way more entertaining than
that
whatever i was talking about
[Laughter]
i just glanced over expecting it still
to be wow and i'm just seeing this guy
light light pulls up
i am paying love
[Laughter]
god there's so many stuff here there's
the high school thing the ace family
auction ace family lost their house bye
bye
channel five baby
coffee zilla dude they lost their house
and now he's getting sued yeah that's
what i wanted beverly hills and then
he's getting sued by the fight people i
think they have four pending lawsuits
the ace family
and just a few days ago it dropped that
the city of beverly hills is suing him
for at least two hundred thousand
dollars and it looks up to six hundred
it looks really bad for him
um you don't want to be sued by a city
yeah
here i'll give you the intel on that one
suit by up for up to a 200 000 or at
least 200 000
he did an impromptu fan meet up on rodeo
which is basically like the cetera the
center of commerce
in los angeles it's one of the like main
shopping hubs where all the designer
stores are right and so
if you shut that street down you're
actually going to cause a lot of money
and damages
the meet-up was they didn't have a
permit
they showed up
they
they
shut down the street the main street for
like five hours
a bunch of police had to come out to try
to stop them
[Music]
this was to promote his fight
ironically
right which he's also being sued for
the worst decision of his good this guy
yeah so he told everyone
i feel like
we need to refresh her and that that was
like the beginning of the end for them
because like when we did that
it was like a year before this uh yeah
and it was before any of these like
scandals and like since we did that
content court their life is just
completely falling apart i definitely
agree with that it was roughly like six
months i believe
six months before yeah i was looking at
the filing but basically yeah it's
really bad um
they told everyone to come down there
and then the they had to call the police
there was like a shitload of cops riot
cops down there trying to break it up
break it up and they were on social
media saying [ __ ] like we're the only
influencers that shut down beverly hills
stuff like that so i was like okay cool
nice job guy uh we're suing you
here's the doc yeah it's bad it's very
bad
oh here's the here's actually the
lawsuit
you can see the evidence they pull
eight so here is him posting it ace
family pull up youtube takeover parade
on [ __ ] permitted on rodeo drive
be ready to take over the street
come shut it down with me and the other
youtube fighters that's evidence my
friend oh my god what an idiot
wow
here's his other homie who's getting
sued
here's dude they've got him they've got
him they've got him this is all from
their stories and we shut down beverly
hills
self-reporting judge
so they just disappeared off social
media
like no they're still posting videos
really
yeah they still get lots of views and
lots of likes too it's wild
here he is again
uh i had to shut the city down before
heading to miami
dude he is definitely [ __ ]
man this guy is such a piece of [ __ ]
it's pretty amazing last video was three
days ago
idiot
his last instagram post is from june
though
and he's still posting youtube videos
though let's see katherine mcbroom how
can you be this big of a [ __ ] up like
holy [ __ ] he's being sued four times
at once
just lost his [ __ ] comments off on
their uh
social media on instagram yeah and they
kept lying about not losing the house
which was another weird thing and yeah
well they definitely lost it
right and she's being sued for her skin
care yeah that's one of the four
okay you guys got a god you should check
out the ambassador
the latest video oh for real okay
yeah so one lawsuit is for social gloves
another lawsuit is from the nba player
who's suing him
for damages from the fight thing
the third lawsuit is from beverly hills
and the fourth lawsuit is catherine's
partner on the beauty line she launched
who apparently she tried to do a hostile
takeover
and and kick him out a [ __ ] crazy
dude
but look at the like ratio it's like
overwhelming man
that's because they got kids in there
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna blast kids
with down flip fight likes
i guess
man do you think these guys literally
had one percent income life ready for
them
they were not so damn greedy and
woefully unethical in their business
dealings i feel bad for the kids too
once they will eventually learn how this
mess really happened they think all
these guys had to do was calm down with
the overspending and also not ruin what
good business with their terrible ideas
and scams a cautionary tale for others
to see too bad history often repeats
itself to those that ignore or are too
ignorant to think it could never happen
to them top comment
in reality you guys got scammed still 95
percent like are my podcasts get more
dislikes than this
look right now i bet our podcast has
more dislikes than this and what the
[ __ ] have i done except be a douche
that's not as bad
it's not as bad as scamming millions of
dollars out of people i don't know the
ratio looks about the same
okay what the [ __ ] exactly
well
were the mcbrooms late
okay i wasn't i was only a few minutes
late and your ass was
walked in half the way into the show
okay
i didn't know about it i told you about
it oh okay bad boys get down votes
that's true
that's a good point yeah
our dislikes weren't bad today but then
you showed the like dislike bar on
screen for a second and they started
going up immediately i think people are
trying to troll you
yeah yeah
what you gonna do
you know
next video having our kids label our
moving box is special
that's brutal
hey look the
the mix scam family are still filming
and the bank owned home oh that's i just
feel bad for i wish their kids weren't
in there exactly that's
but that's part of the scheme they're
you they're they've used their kids from
the beginning and i just it's just sad
yep
as we've been saying recently i really
think
it might be time for youtube to consider
banning this type of content like these
family channels
i'm sure there's some that are wholesome
out there but it just seems like all of
the big ones are horrifically exploited
there needs there needs to be some
regulation to protect these kids from
their parents
this comment says damn my man's lost his
home and his barber
his hair is that bad huh let me see
let me see that haircut i'm thinking
maybe the lineup is what they're doing
so the ace goes there
so
is he promoting a mobile game play
mobile games let's be low this dude is
promoting a solitaire mobile game
that can't be premium
solitaire
best fiends
is that what is that that's like the
game that the influencers oh for real
yeah
i doubt that solitaire grand harvest is
paying top dollar
that would be a let's see let's watch
king would be next in line
king
and then below a king is a
oh are they talking about how like
this is a weird fade how it there's just
like a line it is a little uh ugly
marvel
queen
wow this is sad
and then it could be
this is sad
and then it could be
where's the stops
and then we go
now
they just watch over me like now six
wait can you do my favorite play though
distant one
five
six
seven they play the distant one
play it again
man that's gotta be one of my favorite
moments from the show
those neighbors are gonna be like
locking arms in solidarity oh you get
evicted oh hell yeah yeah wait till i
buy it though
no i'm not buying that [ __ ]
i think that would make you a badass
you'd go from bad boy to badass if you
bought that what the [ __ ] would i do
with his house
it'd just be ultimate petty [ __ ]
content house content house move all of
us oh yeah i'll go live in the ace
family yeah i'll go live in that family
yeah that's awesome to make content for
me sure it went for nine million
are you gonna dollars me nine million
somehow down we'll make nine dogs by
monday i mean
okay it might take a couple years but we
could do it
that house is important i guarantee that
house is like this mcmansion that's just
everything [ __ ] inside it's gotta be the
doors don't close the world's done open
the pipes are busted yeah
it's just horrible you wouldn't like
living there dan no well i mean i'm just
kidding i feel like i deal you know
i find a way
i mean facetious please don't
please don't kill me
the comments are like
ethan's so out of touch ethan's going on
the list
anyway let's watch solitaire this is
interesting eight nine
ten
nine nowhere ten
nine
ten
no freaking wow
he's almost there
three can't use that
eight
seven
no six seven no way one card left
i can't use that i can't use that
nope
no
come on
there it is
you got it
it's congratulating me y'all that's
congratulating me check that out
it makes me feel happy like i actually
want something
so if you guys are interested in this
game all you gotta do is click down in
our description and download it got
somebody else
was pretty real right there it was nice
to actually win something he said he
wants to win something
because the game sucks no because he's
catching so many else his life is
falling apart
dude i feel that i'm gonna go download
that [ __ ] right now
just play that and play that lady check
that out back that up
it makes me feel happy like i actually
want something
oh my god as opposed to all the elves
he's been taking it
listen his disas his life is a disaster
of his own making people
so if you guys are interested in this
game all you got to do is click the link
down in our description and download it
it's free guys and challenge me and if
you guys love it just oh please and
you're not doing solitaire against
anyone also do you know what's why it's
called solitaire
because you play it by yourself solitude
solo
plague solitaire against me guys as much
as me tweet us and thank me later
shall we go to
the hogan patch
the cards are ready let's go
nice view
let's get it let's get a look let's see
if we want if we're interested in this
who's ready to go to the pumpkin patch
i can it makes me sad to see the kids i
can't do it
did not last long
[ __ ]
pill is no joke man
what do we do without men
doing solitaire ads after destroying
their family well if he said solitussi
[Music]
i wonder what seaman thinks about this
really
pushing this oh he
uh emailed me like an hour ago
saying he could call in tomorrow to talk
to liam did we ever get a hold of lane
uh no and also we don't have a show
tomorrow so well well my schedule
revolves around siemens availability
right
i told him we would try and do it on
monday and then he just started
he started uh we'll get him back on the
show we'll think we'll we'll find
something that works whoa
is this real
i
i think i got it i got an email 40
minutes ago from carlos
big connect yeah
what did carlos say
let me read it real quick
how do you know it's real because we
communicated with him once before he
called in before
is it a new opportunity is it a new nft
opportunity
it says bitconnect carlos matos
colon we are changing the world i gotta
go i got the email too yeah
they're coming in waves this must be
another another pyramid scheme yeah for
sure it is i am so excited oh
you called it
no way
i'm going to give you an exclusive
interview to the first major carlos
matos famous big connect 2017 annual
ceremony nft drop auction which is
happening
uh
there's a bunch of uh
private information that i'm not going
to read aloud no should we get him on
well he wants he wants us to come to him
oh okay and it's in new york community
it's in new york on november 4th so he
wants me
to fly out to new york yes to interview
him to help sell his nft
doesn't he do life coaching that's some
high level alpha [ __ ] yeah i thought he
was out of this game
well no he didn't say that
he's been shielding nfts on his twitter
for a while okay
so is it like an nft collection what is
it is it one ft what are we getting one
ft
well it's it's literally an it says nft
of the the 2017 annual bit connect
ceremony that's the fam that's the one
yeah yeah so it's just what the video of
that being
i don't know who would buy that except
me and i'm not gonna buy that
i'm not buying that
well he says
uh
that he sees that the hca issue video is
one of the most watched as it should be
i'm getting in contact with you because
there is something major that is about
to happen
since our h3h3 carlos malto's previous
video did so well i believe you will be
incredibly rewarded by this offer
do you want to fly one of us out to new
york let me tomorrow let me is it
tomorrow well it's on the fourth which
is what thursday does this business
opportunity involve maybe me underneath
you trying to sign people up underneath
me
no no no
some people say this is a
scam you just call into the show carlos
do i really need to fly to new york
i mean this is a big event dude let me
look up this address
that he sent me let's take a peek
at where this is going down whoa
here's the ace family house by the way
this is here's the gallery
this is the house that this is the
website that docks me and here i am on
it
wait show me this is the
send me the image send me the image
carlos is going to [ __ ] kidnap me
like [ __ ]
is that like the subway stop that's what
it must be
that's so funny i look up
wants me the aggression
him at a subway stop at 116th manhattan
i don't know man
this is almost as good as the hut
yo that's where squid game started
wake the [ __ ] up he's to kidnap my ass
you're going to fight carlos down there
like neo and uh
yeah
fighting mr smith in the subway station
that'd be cool
let's go
yo this is wild bro people are saying
he's going to push me into front of the
subway
[Laughter]
i love what's up what's up what's up
what's supposed to be a mistake like
what is this
what is
this
chet is saying ethan's on carlos's
license
yeah i think that that i think that
google maps misinterpreted the address
let me let me try and figure that out
he's flying because it's not even it's
not even the right street the uh
how can there be an address even of a
subway station like that doesn't make
sense right yeah i think i think
well i am so excited to hear about his
proposition for me
[Applause]
we are coming in wigs
wow
all right what else we got i mean we're
gonna watch some channel
five but uh
i don't know how long we've been going
here we're going for a minute
uh
let me check oh this is great so you
guys have seen thank you cam
so you guys have seen their house
okay let me pull this up
so here's their house now going for two
hours 45 minutes by the way oh [ __ ]
let's just
here's their house now
and here's their house after we buy it
open to all
let's go
you know you you know you want to what
would be funny like play on words on
phase
maybe we just call it phase like p h a s
uh
face clan baby
is carlos a bad boy
i think he's a criminal is that about it
does carlos have bad boys
yeah he said in our interview with us
that he was a passionate lover all right
he kept talking about he's a passionate
lover he's into tantric lovemaking that
was one of my favorite calls ever all
right so good let's let's see but
respond tell him to call in he can plug
his nft i'm not flying to new york was
he crashed his [ __ ] mind
what the [ __ ] i mean come on carlos
listen if i didn't have a son to take
care of a pregnant wife i'd be on the
first plane out there trust me
here's their house i've been curious
about it um
okay see
dan is typing like the gabby hannah meme
so fast
it's not that many photos
i want to see the inside i want to see
the interior
jesus dan
can you everyone must hear that right
gabby hannah right exactly
what am i gonna do
well we have channel five still if you
all wanna watch that oh the ins you know
what i'd rather watch
the instagram model
that posed at her father's funeral
this was pretty fire and actually
there's a meme that this reminded me of
um
if you can pull that up
it was a dude
while his grandma or grandpa was in the
hospital like on a ventilator
it was like a a singly songly influencer
a young man
similar vibes
i know i know what you're talking about
yeah yeah thank god
yeah i was lost
here's their a house tour
yeah this is great i just want to give
it to her
i think cam just sent it him sent it i'm
all race family let's move on
no the thing you were yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah this this is [ __ ]
like i figured this was a once in a
lifetime
meme
uh but this girl
proved that it's not kid makes musically
next to dying grandpa in hospital it's
awesome
i will give up
see i'm gonna mute it yeah
but he's saying don't don't give up
grandpa yeah there's someone actually
trying to care for him at this moment
legendary don't you give up no no no
great comments on that i mean he went
viral
top comment says grandpa said please
just pull the plug already
looks like maddie b
yeah for sure well anyway we have the
2.0 version of this
uh influencer by the name of jane
riviera
got all swagged out for her uh
pop her grandpa's funeral
and here she is in front
of her father oh it's her dad damn cold
[ __ ] blooded
first of all is this a proper like
funeral attack i mean that's like
couture that's like hi
well i don't know if it's couture but
that's like sexy right like sure what
her relationship with her father was
like maybe they bonded over fashion
shows
they're coming okay fine i feel like
it's it's cute well what about the next
picture wait you think it's cute for a
funeral i mean it's a black dress one
shoulde like one shoulder off i don't
think it's that crazy should wear that
black dress are you serious yeah i think
you should be showing like i don't think
you should be trying to look sexy at a
funeral i don't think that that's like a
super sexy cut no no okay we need to see
that the other show it would be it would
be more sexy if it were just like
spaghetti straps
right
i mean there's no straps on one side
though one side one second conservative
okay all right we're half in half back
to your face
of the grave just like her unfortunately
not like her dad who's too both absent
and she at least she was tasteful enough
to cover him
it's an open casket funeral
and she's covered the body she's showing
respect but let's go on
hashtag living my best life what do we
think about this one
she's she's
saying a prayer for him
do we like this one uh olivia is this
oh you can see his hands here oh that's
horrible
she's praying for him and looking very
cute
butterfly fly away rip happy you're my
best friend it's a miley cyrus song from
the hannah montana movie
butterfly fly away okay what about this
one okay
olivia defend this one
i can't yeah this one this is where i
can't i cannot defend the actions i can
defend the dress well
she's sticking her butt out to hide his
face that's respectful yeah i'm for sure
oh i see
yo she's got a foot up she's straight
showing off those booty gains
in front of her dad
cadaver
that's
that's wild and olivia that's not the
conservative sizing side of her dress
all right she chose booty gains my dudes
yeah she's showing off the sexy side
yeah so that was the post that's going
viral now like holy [ __ ] you know what
though
the musically one is kind of
more epic isn't it
they're both s here i mean this guy was
a vet too oh my god really
i didn't die face down
for this [ __ ] who took these photos you
think
i'm trying to figure it out you think
timer you think she brought one the
devil actually her mom maybe oh your mom
wait there's eight photos and only three
here i want to see all of them
let me find it i want all of them i
can't get enough
the spirit of her father held the camera
i cannot get enough i want to see all
eight
never give up that's what i'm going to
do when uh
well if i die untimely i want you all to
collab on my name
on my grave with a never give up up up
don't you love me
you also have to think about he took
that in two times speed so like he was
moving in slow motion
yeah what you got for you you gotta just
just go to her instagram
okay here she is she's posted
a bunch about it going viral now
so she's she's
taking click on that top right one she's
taking the opportunity okay i is this
for sure
because either she's on her her account
yeah her account this is her oh yeah
wait wait wait her account got removed i
just sent that she either deleted it or
yeah i think this is a because she okay
and she's also experiencing like a loss
right now
can you imagine huh
well she really did make a mistake she
was going viral so i i think she's
probably probably just nuked a little
too much heat yeah but whatever
i want to look at this that's her dad
yeah this is her account dan
and dan's defense i could i thought it
was an affirmation it says official
account and she is trying to that's
pretty [ __ ] up instagram 100 should
not allow fake accounts to say official
account
but anyway whatever that's her dad
oh i can't link it it's just yeah
because it's a screenshot oh what the
hell this account and this was
i mean
i thought it was her account because i
thought she had screenshotted the
article about herself she's like yeah
look at me okay i got it
check me out i'm in the news
this account is speaking from first
person though so it is a little strange
there's no way this is real
she got like a weird spammy did you
store yeah
well anyway sometimes you win and
sometimes you uh that game of social
media
sometimes it gets you
you think you're dropping a bomb ass
post
sometimes you're just dropping a bomb on
your left
the clown pill is dangerous
look what it did to her like what did it
also make broom sometimes you get what
you [ __ ] deserve
yeah i think that's well said ab the
club pill is a
it giveth and it taketh away both
it's a it's a it's a beautiful and and
dangerous power you have to respect the
cloud pill
like an acid trip you have to
have someone with you who knows what
they're doing right i need that cloud to
do it in a safe space you have to have a
sitter it's like the ring you need like
a samwise with you you can't someone to
carry the load
so you don't put a load in your mom's
bath towel exactly
thank
you we watch you all think i mean i know
everyone's gonna wanna let's just watch
the channel five because [ __ ] it we're
here
we're gonna end up going like 20 hours
never give up
while dan's gone we should discuss
thumbnail title you guys like this one
or would you prefer like an ostomic
broom let's do a poll
let's do a poll um
dan has to do the polls
i'm not sure how to do it on the youtube
ian do you know how to do it uh i don't
think i have access to that love do you
know how to do it
on the downtown notes oh [ __ ] great
dad's gonna be pissed when he sees me
talking about this
cam thinks uh
the cam the cam is the way to go i think
so for sure i think so too absolutely
okay
well in that case let's just watch some
telephone i do have to use the potty
forgive me i know there's been a lot of
debate about me chewing on the show
forgive me
i've been sitting here for over three
hours without a single break
i need to use the restroom what i can't
do a poll i found an option
okay let's do it do we want to do it or
no i'm curious
well basically the other option would be
like austin mcbroom
and let's say let's just say
oh [ __ ] here comes dan
[ __ ]
dan it's like ela's agent 505.0 with the
narcs
you'll try to [ __ ] keep my [ __ ]
if it wasn't for ela every thumbnail
would be like trisha paytas
related
[Music]
what's happening do we like the
thumbnail
i was hoping you didn't have to see this
dan
we're doing a poll on the thumbnail
title oh my god
oh they like it we have good ratings
today
77 percent yes 77
so yes we like it
huge numbers
huge numbers
okay great so we're going to watch the
channel 5 thing
and
i'm just going to use the bathroom real
fast dan you want to read some comments
or whatever and then we'll get into this
yeah i know if we should save this
because like we've been going a long
[ __ ] time here but
it's how long is it
it's like 50 minutes isn't it
yeah which means it's going to take us
an hour to watch at least yeah
yeah but there is a channel 5 trailer
that's pretty epic i watch the trailer i
like that idea
it's in the dark right above it
does he post trailers on this oh he has
like a second channel
i started listening to do an audio book
by the way cam that was your suggestion
oh nice it's fun i i really i really
enjoy
this is just the original
what was that
i'm really enjoying it you know it's
like an acquired skill the audiobook
listening
but it really um is fun
you're listening to it while you uh game
yeah because i you know i play video
games without audio right
because i like to watch or listen to
something
usually i listen to political stuff or
the news or some [ __ ] but this is really
fun it's nice i'm really into it
the pros is very
it's very like i would say compared to
how tolkien writes which can sometimes
just take for [ __ ] ever
i feel like the story is moving in a
much more
uh direct and engageable way
it's like the
like it's moving along things are moving
you know it's fun yeah
no i think it's a great read
tolkien be like the top of the force he
peaked out
everything it's just like [ __ ] i get
it it's a beautiful tree damn
i remember i was reading lord of the
rings
and i was like
in deep i was like almost done with the
second book
and he was and frodo and sam were going
through some elven forest
and they had the cl they were lost and
they had to climb up to the top
where everything was clear to find their
path
and he was talking for so [ __ ] long
about the forest i literally closed the
book and i was just done
i was i said no more i'm [ __ ] done
yeah it's like this music for like
three hours
anyway here's the trailer
this is good already
this is awesome what the [ __ ]
chip makes oh chat makes the hot like i
got style man
yo
oh man you got some flavor too man
no way
no no we live in such a divided world
where everything is so binary it's hard
for people to understand everyone does
chet know what he's doing becoming a
channel 5 meme
like he is
putting himself in the company of the
hoff twins
this is not a good move for him i was
surprised he came back after the last
video but well it was viral he got good
attention
yeah
he needs that clout
it's dangerous damn he is playing flirty
with clowns
it's not for everyone to understand you
know what i mean
that's good
the twins in chat man cut us a
[ __ ] check i'm just waiting i'm
waiting for chet to meet joker man
that's the collab i'm looking forward to
no way
chad why are you tapping our celebrity
guest here on facetime
all right so we're here now with the
island boys no way
when you go oh wait i can't have the
island boys see
andrew gets to talk to whoever he's a
journalist
i want to talk to the island boys no
it's just not right
i'm a journalist i ask questions
yeah some people interviewed charles
manson like exactly right
island which island are you guys from
cuba cuba [ __ ] fake fan i knew that
we have some cool yo what's that
hairstyle called
what's that hairstyle called okay
we got wicks yeah it's called wicks
that's cool man chet would you ever
consider getting wicks for yourself i
don't think i could bro like i don't
think like
my hair like doesn't our [ __ ] gonna drop
down yeah i don't know that they got
spanish in them though so they they hear
nappy here you know
oh i thought oh jesus
why you all the way in norwegian our
[ __ ] gonna drop down vikings
oh they're straight like okay
well i can't wait to get home and watch
that
well that specific one's not out yet but
oh okay yeah got it
the utah rap festival you know in utah
those mormons drop it hard
let's get a little peek i can't help
myself
this just came out today
i made it to the front baby made it to
the front
let's go
suicide suicide boys baby
[Laughter]
i always wonder if these people just pee
their pants
because when you're in the front of a
show like that there is no bathroom
option yeah it happens you think they
just pee themselves that must be
liberating
yeah
they should call this meth and mullets
oh he's got a don't tread on me huh
i'm on taps
what i'm on tabs of what
oh my god dude baby
let's go
to the church of the latter-day saints
who were they what did they believe yeah
what does it mean to be a belong doug a
vlon thug is the one that's you know
you're hardcore bro a real live
[ __ ] thug bro that real thug
life bro that vlon thug light vilon thug
life bro
what's the most belong thug thing you've
ever done man i stole a pocket knife the
other day what why not
what the [ __ ]
no way dude
i gotta get that
vlog no [ __ ] way what's the most
belong thug thing you've ever done man i
stole a pocket knife there no way
no [ __ ] way dude
the other day why why not if you long
thug bro a v long thug bro
if you had to kill one person who would
it be probably hillary clinton hillary
clinton bro all that [ __ ] fake email
[ __ ] about them talking about pizza but
really they're talking about molesting
children and a whole [ __ ] scam of
child trap all right let's uh i'm not
gonna get yelled at the last second of
uh
wait is this actually cash app
is he being sponsored nice cash up
cash
yeah they mentioned him in the last
video too oh for real good for him oh
yeah it is
sponsored by cash app
nice
shout out to the island
life's for me dubs for andrew
that one lady in the last video sent her
reparations with uh
cash
was that an ad
yeah
no what [ __ ] way
wait what that was super well placed
well no at first she's like i don't have
money on me do you have uh
what's this
and he was like i don't have i don't
have that he goes i cash up and then
they did a cut to like say cash at best
uh app for reparations
if that was an ad that was like the
greatest integration ever
i'd love a cash app sponsor but they're
not down with me
i'm not bad boy enough
yo andrew uh is just crushing it it's so
awesome considering what happened to him
at uh all gas no bricks and it's like
people already forgot about that [ __ ]
channel like [ __ ] those guys
dude let me go see what's up with that
graveyard yeah so these guys all gas no
brakes [ __ ] over andrew and basically
stole the ip from him
and he went and started his new channel
and it's already popping off so hard
these guys haven't uploaded in 11 months
eat [ __ ]
eat
[ __ ]
yeah i [ __ ] that up
yeah i wonder if they're uh real happy
with their
decision there so
[ __ ] the man
watch channel 5.
all right
three hours guys
we've done our time we've done our
service you guys want some food
hell yeah i can't eat solid food today
solid food
we can blend up uh you know we'll get
we'll get you a muddy uh
all right thanks for watching everybody
remember
that
there is no leftovers this week on
sunday hassan is out of town right
and remember that um
next we will see you is on thursday
and remember that h3shop.com
the [ __ ] ryan cavanaugh collection is
available
for a little for a little bit longer
here until
november 24th
and remember that this thursday at 10
a.m
pst is teddy fresh black friday sale
30 to 50 off nearly everything on the
website wow
yeah it's a it's going to be mad so
they've lost your alarms at teddy fresh
whoever they are
these folks have lost they have
lost it
do you remember crazy gideon
is he one of those guys he was like
in the local la market he was like the
the
i lost my guy i've lost my mind these
sales these prices
i don't remember that unfortunately so i
wish i could be there with you on that
one but i'm not damn
well guys uh okay so um thank you
everyone thank you all to our members
thank you to everyone for the super
chats
members get episodes a day early
so members will get an episode on
wednesday
um
you want we can watch this
we may be crazy but we're not stupid at
crazy gideon
i knock them deep and sell them keys you
don't buy for me we bought losing money
you don't remember those tours
i never saw one of these i mean i didn't
grow up in l.a remember i was in ventura
i love you wow
you don't buy for me
[Music]
that was awesome
well
lots of love for gideon man
all right guys so have a great week
and we shall see you on wednesday or
thursday
double salute
to the foot soldiers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]